Wer sich möglicherweise erschreckt hat, ob der einen oder andere einen zahlt, kennt das noch nicht, dass dieser Song am Anfang eines jeden Chaos Radios kommt, das hier auf Fritz gesendet wird. Ihr hört den Blue Moon auf Fritz, das heißt wir haben jetzt drei Stunden Zeit miteinander zu quatschen. Chaos Radio bedeutet, dass heute Abend mal wieder der Chaos Computer Club im Haus ist, in diesem Fall der Pawel, der Frank und der Tim. Meine Person Max von Malodki passt auf und fragt doof nach, im Zweifelsfall, wenn irgendwas nicht verstanden wird von mir oder von euch, ich bin ja euer Medium. Und Thema heute Abend, weil wir die Zukunftsloche haben auf Fritz, von Montag bis Freitag, was ich übrigens konsumentenmäßig nur empfehlen kann, geht es auch ein bisschen in die Zukunft noch stärker als sonst beim Chaos Radio. Die sind immer voraus, die Jungs, aber diesmal geht es wirklich weit. Und ihr sollt euch auch so eure Gedanken machen dazu.
Ja genau, jetzt noch mehr Zukunft. Jetzt neu, jetzt auch neu Chaos Radio Nummer 33, obwohl wir letztes Mal schon bei 99 waren. Ich will das gerne noch mal kurz aufklären. Wir haben die 33 seinerzeit vor vielen Jahren mal übersprungen aus diversen Gründen. Und da wir jetzt sozusagen kurz vor unserem Jubiläum sind, haben wir uns gedacht, wir machen den Sack richtig voll und bringen dann auch mal 99 Sendungen zusammen, bevor wir die 100. feiern.
Ihr seid auch so ein bisschen über korrekt manchmal, ne?
Na du weißt doch, wie das mit den Nerds und den Zahlen geht.
Ja klar, muss man vorsichtig sein.
Genau. Im Chat wird ja schon Folge 23, 5 gefördert.
Ist klar. Gut, das Thema in der 33. Ausgabe heute Abend Roboter bzw. Robotik. Genau.
Wir wollen uns der kleinen autonomen Wesen mal annehmen, die uns ja in zunehmendem Maße bevölkern oder zumindest das Versprechen mit sich bringen, dass sie das demnächst tun. Wir haben viele Roboter schon in unseren gängigen kulturellen Visionen, wie in Filmen, in Büchern erlebt und sicherlich hat der ein oder andere da auch nochmal so seine ganze private Vision, wie es sich denn mit diesen Maschinen verhalten wird. Wir wollen mal so ein bisschen zurückblättern, wo denn das Ganze so in etwa seinen Ursprung nahm, ohne jetzt zu sehr hier die Historikerrolle spielen zu wollen, auch ein wenig beleuchten, was so eigentlich der Stand der Technik genau ist und wohin die Reise gehen könnte und das wollen wir natürlich auch gemeinsam mit euch tun und euch auch ein bisschen einbinden, insbesondere in die philosophische Auseinandersetzung da drüber, ob denn das etwas ist, was wir wirklich haben wollen, haben müssen und wie denn das ist, wenn es denn mal da ist.
Ist das ein weißer Kragen, den ich da blitzen sehe? Nein. Gut, 0331 77 91 10, das sei schon mal zum Anfang gesagt, ist die Nummer, die Hotline von Fritz, über die könnt ihr teilnehmen heute Abend am Chaosradio, denn es ist eure Sendung auch mit, das heißt ihr könnt sie mitgestalten und mitreden und ihr könnt wahrscheinlich auch wieder über diverse elektronische Kanäle teilnehmen, wenn ihr mal eine Mailadresse habt. Ist es denn auch die 33?
Ja, es sollte die 33. Schickt mal sonst an mail.chaosradio.ccc.de. Ich bin mir gerade nicht so sicher, ob wir die Mailadresse wirklich eingerichtet haben. Ansonsten sind wir durchaus am Start. Es gibt Streams, mindestens ein Stream. Ich sammle das gleich hier nochmal mit den Streams, da ist nämlich gerade noch ein bisschen unklar, was wirklich läuft. Auf jeden Fall gibt es den Real Audio Stream von Fritz, aber wir haben dann noch ein OX Stream, ein QuickTimes Stream und sicherlich irgendwo noch ein MP3 Stream. Das trage ich gleich mal nach, für die Leute in der Lage sind, das weiter zu lehnen. Wir sind hier auch im Chat am Werk auf irc.freenote.net im Kanal Chaosradio. Ich lese da mit und tippe ein bisschen mit, sobald ich dazu komme. Und das reicht ja auch erstmal. Ah ja, genau. Entschuldigung, es gibt die Mitmach-Seite auf der Wikipedia und dort könnt ihr euch auch hinterlassen.
Was hast du noch mal das Wikipedia-Stichwort dazu an? Chaosradio.
Das Wikipedia-Stichwort?
Also worunter man diese Seite findet in der Wikipedia.
Achso, naja, das ist eine etwas längere Uhr. Ich schwitze gerade ein bisschen, wie ich das jetzt am besten übergebe, weil auf der Chaosradio... Ja, Chaosradio, das ist alles, wir hatten irgendwie gerade so viel zu tun, das ist alles ganz furchtbar.
Und möglicherweise werdet ihr euch natürlich über die letzte, sehr moderne und sehr neue Art und Weise der Kommunikation mit euch irgendwie erschrecken. Wir senden natürlich auch über eine Radiofrequenz und die erfahrt ihr ja unter fritz.de, wenn ihr nicht wisst, welche das ist. Ansonsten spiele ich jetzt ein bisschen Musik, ich lasse die Jungs mal so langsam hochbooten und dann legen wir gleich los. Meine junge Frau singt von ihren Haaren. Das soll ich aber nicht ablenken. Ihr hört das Chaos Radio. Aufritz hat gerade angefangen. Das heißt, wir haben noch drei Stunden knapp Zeit zu reden über das Thema heute Abend in der Zukunft Woche aufritz. Und das ist diesmal Robotik beziehungsweise Roboter an sich, die ja dann möglicherweise in der Zukunft auch auf uns zuströmen werden und unsere Gesellschaft irgendwie beherrschen. Bevor wir da hinkommen, müssen wir aber erst mal die Basics klären. Und da fängt Frank, so wie ich das verstanden habe, mal in seiner Abstellkammer an.
Ist das richtig? Fast, ja. Also einer der Gründe, warum wir diese Sendung machen ist, dass ich vor einiger Zeit einen neuen Staubsauger gekauft habe. Und also genau sagt die Firma einen neuen Staubsauger. Wir haben halt kein Reinigungspersonal. Deswegen habe ich halt einen Roboter Staubsauger gekauft. Das ist ein kleines rundes Ding. Das ist perfekt in der Lage, den Fußboden sauber zu machen, alle wesentlichen Hindernisse zu umfahren, sich meistens nicht zu verhakelen, außer bei zwei speziellen Konfigurationen von Kameln, mit denen es nicht klarkommt. Und eigentlich doch einen sehr befriedigenden Gesamteindruck machte. Und das war so meine erste Begegnung außerhalb von so Lego Robotern und ähnlichen Spielzeugrobotern mit so einem richtigen Roboter, der mal so richtig Dinge tut seit so etlichen Jahren. Ich habe in einer frühen Jugend mal Industrieroboter programmiert, so nebenbei in der Schule, dann lange mit dem Thema nichts mehr zu tun gehabt. Und jetzt dann kam da plötzlich so ein Ding, war irgendwie billig, also relativ billig, kostete so 300 Dollar und macht halt einen Fußboden sauber. Und dann habe ich mal so ein bisschen angefangen zu gucken, was passiert dann eigentlich in dem Feld und war dann doch fasziniert zu entdecken, dass vieles von dem, wovon man immer so geredet hat früher, so was ein Roboter denn so können, könnte und sollte, überhaupt nicht der Kern der Entwicklung ist, da geht es eigentlich gar nicht hin, sondern das entwickelt sich ganz anders als früher gedacht. Der Ursprung des Begriffs Roboter, der kommt von Carl Chopick, wenn ich mich nicht irre.
Ja, genau aus dem Theaterstück RUR, Rossum's Universalny Robot, wobei Rossum auch noch ein Wortspiel ist und Verstand bedeutet und da waren das in diesem Theaterstück damals allerdings keine mechanischen Maschinen, sondern organische Androiden, die eben als Sklaven gezüchtete Menschen, die dort in Tanks herangezogen wurden und dann zur Fronarbeit benutzt werden. Also Roboter sind eigentlich Sklaven vom Ursprung her.
Aber es war damals in der Geschichte mehr so ein Bio-Roboter, ein Klon mit begrenzter Funktionalität oder wie?
Ja, ja, also das ist jedenfalls der Ursprung und das wurde dann ganz schnell aufgenommen und dann für alle Arten von ja, Dingen mit Hirn und Tentakeln benutzt.
Aber insgesamt, ja, also die, die so die Gänge die Vorstellung von so einem Roboter ist, er läuft auf zwei Beinen, hat zwei Arme, eine viergegen Kopf, blitzende Augen und hält im Zweifel irgendwie die schöne Frau aus dem Sci-Fi-Film gefangen und droht halt an böse Dinge mit ihr zu tun, also zu sein so eine Art elektronischer kleiner Godzilla. Und das hat aber erstaunlich wenig mit der Realität zu tun. Wenn man sich so den typischen Roboter anguckt, der hat halt einen Arm, ist festgeschraubt, orange angespritzt und in der Lage, ein Werkstück aus der Drehbank in ein Roboterauto hinzulegen, was irgendwie zur nächsten Werkstation fährt. Und diese Diskrepanz ist natürlich auch faszinierend, weil natürlich die öffentliche Wahrnehmung von Robotern wird ja eigentlich immer geprägt von so diesen Showgeräten, die irgendwie rumstehen. Es gibt natürlich jetzt so eine Menge Geräte wie zum Beispiel so ein Honda Asimo, der halt auf zwei Beinen laufen kann und so ein bisschen Fußball spielen und mit den Händen wackeln kann.
Der, das muss man dazu sagen, wirklich sehr sehr gut auf zwei Beinen laufen kann. Also das sieht schon richtig elegant aus. Der kann auch Treppen hoch und runter steigen oder?
Das war doch der Asimo, ne?
Der kann auch schon laufen, allerdings mit nur drei Stundenkilometern.
Na gut, ich meine 100 Millionen Dollar später möchte man eigentlich was erwarten. Das ist nicht die Summe, die ich bisher darin gesteckt hab.
Also pro 3 Stundenkilometer 100 Millionen Dollar. Das ist noch eine Menge, ne? Aber ich meine, gut, wie lange haben die Autos gefressen?
Am besten funktionieren Roboter bislang in Filmen. Alles andere, was sonst so real rumsteht, könnte man eigentlich auch guten Gewissens noch als Automaten bezeichnen.
Ich weiß nicht, also meinen Staubsauger wollte ich schon als Roboter bezeichnen, weil der fährt gegen den Fuß und dann macht er ein Düdel Lüth. Und dann fährt er um deinen Fuß rum und wenn du das mal gesehen hast, dann glaubst du schon, sprich dem Ding einigermaßen unmittelbar an eine Wesenseigenschaft zu. Also man begreift ihn nicht mehr so als Automat wie sagen wir mal sein Staubsauger, der dann einen Ausknopf hat, sondern der macht halt schon so Dinge. Also der ist halt schon in der Lage relativ komplex zu agieren.
Aber das ist ja schon ziemlich feiner Grad, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe, weil ein Automat, der zum Beispiel, oder sagen wir mal ein Roboter, der Sachen in Autos einbaut, der macht ja auch immer nur den gleichen Arbeitsprozess. Der macht er sehr fein und relativ komplex, aber ist das der Grad der Komplexität, der da eine Rolle spielt, weil zum Beispiel neue Mercedes Fahrzeuge oder BMW oder was auch immer haben zum Beispiel einen Spur Korrektur Assistent. Das heißt, du fährst irgendwie zu weit auf die eine Seite, dann lenkt dich das Auto irgendwie sanft wieder zurück, was ja auch eine eigene Aktion ist. Könnte man dann auch als Roboter bezeichnen, eher als Automat?
Das ist eben genau der Kern der Diskussion. Also ich denke, dass das, was wir früher so als Roboter bezeichnet haben, das wird es halt noch eine Weile nicht geben, aber jede Menge Funktionen, die man mit so Robotern assoziieren würde, nämlich zum Beispiel selber Auto fahren können, die wird es halt in Autos geben, was natürlich viel mehr Sinn macht als in einem menschenförmigen Roboter. Man will ja irgendwie keinen menschenförmigen Chauffeur am Steuer seines Mercedes haben, sondern möchte, wenn man selber fährt, irgendwie irgendwo auf den Knopf drücken und sagen, jetzt bin ich müde, fahr mich nach Hause.
Es sei denn, es liegt einem was daran, dass es so aussieht, als würde dort ein Mensch sitzen.
Kostet dann halt mehr.
Also die Grenzen zwischen Robotern und Automaten sind natürlich fließend, gerade bei diesen mal Lackier Robotern. Man redet in der Regel von Lackier Robotern, aber von Schweißautomaten beispielsweise, sodass offenbar ein subtiler Unterschied dazwischen besteht, ob jetzt dieses Gerät, dieser Arm schweißt oder lackiert, weil zum Lackieren wahrscheinlich dann doch etwas mehr Handfertigkeit gehört oder dass das einfach mehr aussieht.
Nene, der Lackier Roboter guckt nach, ob da tatsächlich genug Lack drauf ist. Also der kann halt tatsächlich ein Feedback auf seine Arbeit wahrnehmen. Interessanterweise auch der Unterschied bei so modernen Industrierobotern, bei richtigen, dass die oft noch halt eine relativ ausgefeilte Sensorik haben. Also die machen nicht nur mal die Drehmaschine aufmacht, den Arm um richtigen Augenblick hin und das Werkstück rauszunehmen, sondern die können tatsächlich dann zum Beispiel auch eine Qualitätsprüfung mit Hilfe einer Kamera machen. Das sind ja sozusagen komplexe Maschinensysteme. Das ist ja nicht nur dieser Arm, den man da wahrnimmt, sondern irgendwann halt auch noch Sensorik dazu und jede Menge andere Dinge. Und die sind halt flexibel. Man kann sie halt relativ einfach von einem Task auf den anderen, also von einer Aufgabe auf die andere umprogrammieren. Und ich glaube, das ist halt genau der Unterschied, dass es halt nicht nur einfach irgendwie eine Schweißnaht irgendwie immer hoch und runter zieht, sondern dass es in der Lage ist zu sagen, okay, das Auto, was jetzt kommt, ist übrigens ein Kleinwagen und kein LKW. Und da muss die Schweißnaht dahin und nicht dahin.
Also Hand und Hirn könnte man kurz zusammengefasst sagen.
Wobei das natürlich auch so ein bisschen die industrielle und jetzt herangehensweise ist, das, was wir vorhin kurz hatten, wo es darum ging, dass du, Frank, das Bild aufgemacht hast hier, dass es sich immer bei Robotern um irgendwelche Wesen handelt, die irgendwie die Frau entführen. Ja, das klassische Bild aus dem Film. Da geht es ja dann irgendwie jetzt in der Vision der Roboter für die Zukunft doch im Grunde darum, dass es sich um Roboter handelt, die künstliche Intelligenz beziehungsweise künstliche Emotionen erzeugen können und damit sozusagen auch den Fehler begehen können oder die Tat oder ähnliches.
Also ich glaube, als ihr gesagt habt, die Roboter funktionieren am besten im Film. Und mein Roboter, den ich heute kaufe, naja, der fährt so ein bisschen mir gegen den Fuß und fängt an zu piepen.
Und der fährt drum rum.
Aber wenn man sich die ersten Roboter, gut jetzt wird es ein bisschen schwierig, aber es gibt natürlich auch andere Beispiele, also auch die, also zum Beispiel einer dieser bekannteren Filmroboter Robby aus dem Film der verbitten Planet heißt im Weltall genannt. Genau. Ganz lustiger Film eigentlich.
1956 muss man dazu sagen.
Ja, man muss auch dazu sagen, dass er mit Leslie Nielsen war und man muss auch dazu sagen, dass es eigentlich der Film ist, wo sich Star Trek alles abgeguckt hat, wo so wirklich alles, so Pille und Kirk und auch so die gesonstige Rahmenhandlung.
Also wer ein richtiger Trekkie ist und den Film nicht gesehen hat, dem fehlt was.
Da werdet ihr euch wundern.
Wie auch immer.
Auf jeden Fall ist Robbie ein ziemlich klobiger Kasten. So also wirklich noch so der Weihnachtsbaum unter den Robotern, der irgendwie etwas unbehändet durch die Gegend fährt, tütet, blinkt und irgendwie rotierende Kreise um sich herum hat. Aber trotzdem ist es ihnen halt immer eigen, dass sie ebenso auch eine gewisse Intelligenz haben. Und ich glaube, das ist eben die Faszination, warum auch in der Roboterentwicklung so sehr daran gearbeitet wird, ihm zwei Beine zu geben und zwei Arme und natürlich auch einen Kopf, um einfach das Ebenbild zu schaffen, um einfach die Herausforderungen quasi als Vorlage von sich selbst zu sehen. Das können wir natürlich diskutieren.
Ich glaube, dass der Grund, warum humanoid Roboter, also menschenförmige Roboter entwickelt werden, ist, dass nur die sinnvoll sind in einer Welt, die halt für einen Menschen geschaffen ist. Weil, wenn man sich die Welt mal so anguckt, ist die Welt für 1, 75 große männliche Wesen, die 75 Kilo wiegen, geschaffen. Wenn du von dieser Norm abweichst, hast du schon wieder Probleme.
Die armen Frauen.
Genau. Und so ein Roboter, wenn er nützlich sein soll, soll hinter dir herlaufen können, deinen Einkauf nach Hause tragen, die Treppe hoch tragen können und so weiter und so fort, dann ist der zwangsläufig menschenförmig. Da bleibt ihm nicht viel anderes übrig. Aber ein anderer Trend, den ich halt sehe, ist, wenn die Umwelt behindertengerecht wird, das heißt also, es überall Rampen gibt, Fahrstühle gibt, genügend breite Türen gibt und so weiter und so fort, dann wird sie damit automatisch auch Roboter gerechter. Das heißt, man kann dann auch mit Robotern in dieser Umwelt agieren, die halt nicht zwei Beine haben, sondern halt, die sich halt sagen wir mal wie ein Rollstuhl fortbewegen. Und das glaube ich, so ein Trend, der es dann einfacher machen wird, irgendwann zum Beispiel einen Roboter zu bauen, der den Einkauf nach Hause trägt. Weil, wenn er davon ausgehen kann, dass du A, einen Fahrstuhl zu Hause hast, da brauchst du schon mal keine zwei Beine, B, dass das Einkaufszentrum in die Rechte ist, sind die meisten, dann kommt er irgendwie da her wie mit vier Rädern und das macht die ganze Sache schon mal wesentlich einfacher. Der kann ja halt einfach hinterher fahren.
Ihr kommt ins Spiel. Ihr merkt schon, das Thema hat ziemlich viele Facetten. Was könntet ihr euch denn vorstellen? Was für einen Roboter würdet ihr euch wünschen? Wenn ihr jetzt die freie Wahl hättet, ihr habt eure ganzen Kram, die ihr erledigen müsst, was würdet ihr euch wünschen? Und für den Fall, dass jetzt auf die Idee kommt, Steuererklärungsroboter, den wünsche ich mir schon. 0331 77 97 1 1 0 ist die Nummer der Fritz Hotline. Und ihr könnt euch natürlich auch schon mal Gedanken darüber machen, wohin das möglicherweise führen könnte. Am Telefon ist der Tristan aus Schöneberg Berlin. Tagchen, Tristan.
Also ich kann gleich mal anschließen an das Thema, soll der rollen oder laufen. Und zwar bin ich mit zwei Jungs am basteln. Und zwar mache ich Jahresarbeiten mit denen für deren 12-Klass-Abschluss in der Waldorfschule. Und zwar macht der eine einen sechsbeinigen Laufroboter und der andere baut eine Hand nach, die er sozusagen mit der Schieblehre anhand seiner Knochenlänge anatomisch finibel genau abgemessen hat und die Teile in Aluminium nachgebaut hat. Es war alles im Vierkant-Profil, aber sieht trotzdem erschreckend echt und tot aus, wenn einem das Ding auf auf den Schoß fällt oder sonst wohin. Das ist irgendwie ziemlich komisch, so was zu sehen, was von den Proportionen sehr menschlich ist, aber doch irgendwie aus Metall besteht. Ja und zu dem Lauchproboter würde ich sagen, dass es eben mich und ihn, mein Kumpel, mit dem ich das baue, ziemlich fasziniert, diese Problematik und auch diese Herausforderung, eben dieses Laufen, was ja doch wesentlich komplexer ist, als man so denkt, wenn man jemanden irgendwo langlaufen sieht. Dieses eben zu adaptieren und irgendwie nachzubauen und nachzuahmen und zu gucken, wie schwierig, wie viele Mechanismen brauchen wir, wie viel Sensorik, wie viel und so weiter. Also es ist schon erstaunlich. Also es gibt ja ganz einfache Pendelläufer oder wie auch mal man die nennen soll. Das sind sozusagen rein mechanische Konstruktionen. Die schubst man einmal an und die laufen erstaunlich weit nur durch ihren pendelnden Schwung. Das sind irgendwie so ein, zwei Meter hohe Konstruktionen aus Stahlblechen, eine Handvoll Kugellager und ein paar Gewichte und zwei Gummischuhe. Und die können sehr gut laufen. Allein das zeigt ja schon, dass Laufen an und zu sich ziemlich effektiv ist. Aber auf einer ebenden Fläche rollt man halt doch effektiver, weil man einfach zwei Kugellager mit einem Rad draufschneit und los geht's. Aber wenn jetzt das Gelände ein bisschen unebender wird, dann ist natürlich interessant, dass eben nicht mit irgendwelchen Land Rover ähnlichen Autos, sondern vielleicht zu Fuß.
Sobald das auf dem Mars ja so gemacht wird.
Genau, da gibt es ja entweder diese vielrädrigen Dinger oder eben wirklich laufende Viecher. Und dieses Laufen ist eben wirklich sehr interessant. Also wir haben das probiert, möglichst minimalistisch nachzubauen. Also das Standardbeispiel ist die sogenannte Stabheuschrecke, die ziemlich einfache Laufgeometrien hat. Also ihr eines Gelenk im Bein und das Bein ist gelenkt am Körper noch mal dran. Und dann geht der Fuß sozusagen immer hoch, runter und vor und zurück. Und das haben wir alles gemacht mit einem Exzenter, zwölf Fäden und 60 Federn ungefähr. Und ja, das Stück Platine genommen als Motherboard sozusagen als Körper, 10 mal 20 Zentimeter. Und darauf findet die ganze Stadt.
Und das machst du an der Schule mit zwölf Klässlern?
Ja, also ich war selber an der Schule vor ein paar Jahren und habe, also ich bin sozusagen Mentor für die, die ihre Jahresarbeiter machen. Also Jahresarbeit heißt, dass sie ein Jahr Zeit haben, sich irgendein Thema auszudenken, ihnen was auszuarbeiten, 30 Minuten zu schreiben und eine praktische Präsentation von 45 Minuten grob auf die Bühne zu bringen sozusagen. Und da helfe ich diesen beiden Jungs eben. Der eine macht halt diese Roboterhand und der andere diesen Laufroboter.
Ein sehr ungewöhnliches Thema für eine Wallau-Schule, oder?
Ja, genau.
Also nur so gefragt, oder?
Ja, also finde ich interessant, dass man halt sozusagen einfach schon an der Schule mit solchen Technologien direkt spielen kann.
Und wie ist euer Verhältnis zu diesen Maschinen? Also jetzt mal so rein angenommen, ihr könnt jetzt alle technischen Probleme in kürzester Zeit lösen und dann eben sofort auch immer noch eins nachlegen. Also in welche Richtung denkst du, wirst du das weiterentwickeln wollen? Was soll die Maschine können und was wäre sie dann?
Also er würde das Teil in den perfekten sechslangigen Land Rover entwickeln, der sozusagen durch das unwegigste Gelände, was man sich vorstellen kann, zum Beispiel mein Zimmer nach so einer Basket-Session oder so, problemlos durchladen könnte.
Und dann tut was?
Also was soll er tun?
Von A nach B laufen und vielleicht noch irgendwie 100 Gramm Nutzlast transportieren oder so.
Also ihr denkt oder erst mal sozusagen über die technischen Probleme, um die technischen Probleme willen nach.
Wie würdest du ihn steuern?
Unter meiner Drehbank den Schraubenschlüssel hervorholen oder was der Geier ist. Wie wir den steuern wollen.
Ja, also was wäre sozusagen dein Wunschinterface? Reden wir da jetzt über eine Fernbedienung oder reden wir über Aufzuruf oder Gedanken lesen?
Oh Gott, das ist ja im Prinzip nur Frage, wie man was programmiert. Also im Prinzip wäre es natürlich möglichst schön, wenn das Ding möglichst selbstständig wäre. Also man würde ihm am Anfang einen Auftrag geben nach dem Motto, hol die drei runtergefallenen Schrauben unter der Drehbank hervor und leg sie in die richtige Schublade am anderen Ende des Zimmers und dann geht's los.
Also, oh Gott.
Also sonst erlauben.
Also unser Ziel ist im Prinzip die technischen Hürden sozusagen zu überwinden. Und wie gesagt, also wenn man das alles überwinden könnte, wäre eigentlich glaube ich das Ziel, dass man möglichst viel Effekt hat im Sinne von mit möglichst kleinem Körper möglichst große Hindernisse zu überwinden oder ähnliche Sachen. Und dafür braucht man natürlich dann später möglichst intelligente Geschichten. Also bis jetzt haben wir, um ganz realistisch zu bleiben, um die technischen Probleme nicht alle überwunden haben sozusagen. Das Teil wird ja über einen Exzenter angesteuert. Also das heißt ein Motor, der über Schneckengetriebe an einer Kurbel dreht. Und an dieser Kurbel sind eben zwölf Seile befestigt. Und die werden, an denen wird dann kreisförmig immer gezogen und wieder locker gelassen. Und über Federmechanismen und Umlenkhebel und sonst was werden damit halt die Beine hochgezogen und nach vorne gezogen, wieder runter gelassen und nach hinten gezogen. Und dieses nach hinten ziehen passiert eben über eine Federkraft, sodass man die auch davon abhalten könnte, indem man die Beinchen einfach blockiert. Und wir spielen mit dem Gedanken, wenn wir das zeitlich hinkriegen, ein kleines Modellbau Servo zu nehmen, einen kleinen Modellbauempfänger und einen kleinen Akku, sodass wir sozusagen mit einem Servo die Beinchen am nach hinten Flippen stufenlos hindern können, sodass wir sozusagen in der Lage sein müssen, Kurven zu laufen.
Machst du sowas beruflich oder wie kamst du auf die Idee?
Ne, das ist mein Hobby. Also ich weiß nicht, also mein erstes Wort war wahrscheinlich Transistor oder Widerstand und...
Und dann kam Waldorfschule.
Und welches...
Ja, das schließt sowas nicht aus.
In welcher Stadt machst du das?
Ich bin Berliner. Und ja, was ich noch sagen wollte, was mich sehr angeregt hat und mir wirklich in den Fingern kribbelt, ich hab, da ich gerade eine Ausbildung als technischer Assistent für Metallografie und Werkstoffanalyse mache am Letteverein in Berlin, wo ich sozusagen viel mit Metallen und Legierungen und sonst was zu tun habe, bin ich irgendwann mal bei irgendeiner Tagte auf einer Tür von einem Institut an einen sehr komischen Werkstoff gekommen, will ich noch kurz erzählen, die Episode. Und zwar ist das eine Büroklammer gewesen aus ziemlich weichen Draht. Und man bat uns, diese Büroklammer doch irgendwie in jeglicher Art, solange es kein Knoten ist, zu verbiegen. Es war ziemlich weicher Draht, so Lötzchen ähnlich sozusagen. Und wir taten es alle ganz fleißig. Dann ging der Mensch mit dem Feuerzeug rum und hielt es kurz darunter und schwupps war das Teil wieder in einem Büroklammer zurückgeformt. Das Ganze heißt Formgedächtnis-Legierungen, ist so seit ein paar Jahren ziemlich heiß umforschter Stoff und funktioniert so, dass sich bei einer gewissen Temperatur, die man über Legierungskomponenten einstellen kann, eine Umwandlung stattfindet, bei der der Werkstoff einen ziemlich hohen Verformungsgrad wieder rückgängig macht und sich sozusagen an seine Uhrform erinnert.
Aber ist es nicht so, dass die für wenn man das für Roboterbewerbe verwenden will, dass das Problem A die Kraft ist, die man erzeugen kann und B die Rückverformungsgeschwindigkeit?
Das sind Probleme und genau da will ich mich jetzt rantasten, in dem ich gedacht habe, Mensch, das würde auf jeden Fall ein irrer Gag sein, wenn man quasi meine sogenannte Walking Alkaline bauen könnte, in dem man einfach eine Migno Batterie nimmt und die auf Sechsebeinen durch die Gegend latschen lässt, indem man einfach einen kleinen IC nimmt, der die sechs Beinchen, die mit Heizwindungen umwickelt sind, die Beinchen bestehen aus dünnen Draht, so unter 1 mm Durchmesser und das Teil dann durch die Gegend läuft. Also es gibt Probleme dabei, aber ich habe sie noch nicht erforscht, weil ich noch nicht im Besitz solcher tollen Formgelenkligierungen bin. Ich habe jetzt aber unterschiedliche Institute angeschrieben und bei einem Glück gehabt, also man kann die auch schon kaufen im Internet.
Ich habe da ein bisschen gespielt für einen anderen Zweck und zwar lenkbare Modellraketen und da ist halt das Problem, dass die Abkühlungsgeschwindigkeit ist halt relativ gering und wenn man da nicht aktiv zulüftet, dann war zumindest bei den Sachen, die ich da gekauft hatte, das Problem, dass sie nicht schnell genug wieder kontrahiert haben. Also dass sozusagen die Rückformung halt nicht schnell genug wieder stattfand, als dass man da irgendwie sinnvoll was mit anfangen konnte.
Darf ich mal kurz nachhaken, was hast du denn mitgebaut?
Na ich wollte halt einfach nur eine Steuerung bauen, mit der ich eine Tragfläche von der Modellrakete steuern konnte. Also ohne noch einen großen Servo in dieser Rakete zu bauen.
Na gut, da sind natürlich die Zeiten dann ein bisschen...
Richtig, genau...
.wenn die Raketen einfach so scheiße schnell sind.
Richtig, genau.
Ich mein, das ist ja bei kleinen langsamen Laufrobotern wahrscheinlich noch nicht so das Problem. Vor allem wenn ich wirklich dünne Drähte nehme von 0, 5er Stärke, die kühlen ja innerhalb von einer Sekunde von 60 auf oder von 120 auf 60 Grad wieder runter, meines Weges. Und damit habe ich dann die Umwandlung wieder geschafft.
E2, ne? Ihr könnt ja gerne mal zusammen Drahtworkshop machen, aber es geht ja heute Abend auch um ethisch-moralische Fragen, wo wir auch irgendwie hinkommen wollen. Und außerdem haben wir ja unsere Nachrichten und unser kleiner Nachrichtendraht, der Gerald Kötterhahnrich ist schon hier und er ist auch schon ausgeformt. Also sein Gedächtnis hat sich quasi erinnert.
Frage noch, unter welcher, wo gibt es hier denn Internet? Was meinst du? Die Formgedächtnissiegerung.
Das hat der Frank jetzt nicht mehr gehört.
Schreib uns einfach kurz eine Meldung und antworte dich darauf.
Kann ich gerade nicht, weil ich kein Internet hab.
Bleib mal sowieso kurz noch am Telefon und wir melden uns gleich nochmal.
In Stamberg, Sternwunder 3, 2.
22 Uhr 32. Mit den Nachrichten und mit dem Wetter natürlich. In der Nacht fällt stellenweise Schnee und es kann glatt werden bei minus eins bis minus vier Grad. Morgen soll es dann meist bewölkt sein. Ab und zu kann es weiteren Schnee geben bei maximal ein Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Gerald Kötterheinrich.
Die italienischen Truppen bleiben im Irak. Der Senat in Rom stimmte mit großer Mehrheit den Einsatz zu verlängern. Irakische Extremisten fordern den Abzug der Truppen. Vor einer Woche haben sie eine italienische Journalistin in ihre Gewalt gebracht. Israelsche Siedler sollen finanziell entschädigt werden, wenn ihre Siedlungen im Gazastreifen aufgelöst werden. Das hat das israelische Parlament beschlossen. Der Gesetzentwurf sieht vor, dass ab dem Sommer mehr als 20 Siedlungen geräumt werden. Bundesfinanzminister Eichel erwartet harte Verhandlungen über eine Reform des EU-Stabilitätspakt. Er gehe nicht davon aus, dass es noch heute eine Einigung gebe, sagte Eichel. Seit dem Abendverhandeln in Brüssel die Finanzminister über eine Aufweichung der Kriterien. Die Bundeswehr hält an ihren Plänen für das sogenannte Bombodrom im Norden Brandenburgs fest. Das Übungsgelände sei als einziges in Deutschland für die Luftwaffe geeignet, das sagte der parlamentarische Verteidigungsstaatssekretär Wagner. Zum Sport in der Zwischenrunde des UEFA Pokals haben sich Schacht Jordanić und Schalke 1-1 unentschieden getrennt. Parma und Stuttgart ebenfalls unentschieden gespielt, 0-0 unentschieden. Genau und im Achtelfinale des BBL Pokals hat der Basketball Bundesligis Alba Berlin auswärts gegen Röndorf 104 zu 60 gewonnen und steht damit im Viertelfinale. Der Verkehr auf Fritz keine aktuellen Meldungen, es glattrauchten, teilweise fahrtvorsichtig.
Gute Fahrt.
Ihr hört sie, ihr mögt sie, dann wählt sie. Ihr bestimmt sie und wählt eure Lieblingssongs in die 20 plus 1.
Fritz.
Ja, es gab ja noch die Nachfrage, wie dieser Draht heißt, der sich bei Erwärmung verformt und dann bei Abkühlung wieder in seine alte Form zurückfindet. Der Suchbegriff dafür ist Ni-Ti-Noel. Das ist die Abkürzung für eine von diesen Legierungen, die diese eingeschafft haben und den findet man auch so in Roboticshops und Modellbauschops, wo man halt so zu Behör für Selbstbastelroboter finden kann. Nochmal der Name ist Ni-Ti-Noel.
Jetzt denkt ihr natürlich, wer ist das und was erzählt ihr mir da an? Nun ihr hattet das Chaos Radio und heute Abend geht es um Roboter. Das heißt, sowas könnte euch noch das eine oder andere Mal passieren. Zweieinhalb Stunden noch Zeit zu reden, ist ein sehr, sehr vielfältiges Thema. Und deswegen müssen wir uns auch so kleine, feine Ecken erst mal rauspicken, über die zu reden wäre. Was wollen wir denn jetzt für eine Facette beleuchten?
Ja, also vor allem interessieren uns natürlich auch eure Meinung und Erfahrung. Habt ihr selber einen Roboter oder etwas, was ihr so nennen wollt? Also sei es jetzt ein Konsumergerät, was robotische Eigenschaften hat.
Meinst du jetzt so Konrad Electronics 99 Euro Fernsteuerung? Kann mir so eine Tasse Orangensaft zum Bett bringen zum Beispiel?
Ja, oder so ein Spielzeug Roboter oder halt irgendwie einen Roboter Kollegen auf Arbeit, mit dem man zusammenarbeiten muss.
Also habt ihr irgendwie der Android von dem an?
Habt ihr schon tatsächlich persönliche Erfahrungen mit etwas, was ihr als Roboter bezeichnen wollt? Das interessiert uns.
Oder baut ihr halt welche? Das war natürlich eben auch eine sehr interessante, weil es gibt einfach immer mehr Leute, die sich mit der Technik auch beschäftigen. Da ist ja Deutschland an sich kulturell etwas hinterher. Die Japaner, die können ja gar nicht genug davon kriegen, von diesem Thema. Auch bei den Amerikanern ist es schon längere Zeit ein heißes Ding, aber hier aus nicht so ganz klaren Gründen weniger. Aber vielleicht ist das auch nur unser Eindruck und ihr könnt diesen Eindruck etwas entschärfen.
Fassen wir es doch einfach mal als polizeiliche Frage. Hatten Sie Kontakt mit irgendeinem Roboter? Rufen Sie jetzt an 033 177 97 110. Wär schon schön, wenn ihr ein paar Geschichten habt. Weil ich muss sagen, mich haben diese Dinge auch immer fasziniert. Ich musste leider aber immer wieder feststellen, dass es eigentlich ungenügendes Material war, was man da gekriegt hat. Das sah auf der Packung immer ganz toll aus. Der konnte alles, der konnte sprechen. Der war schlau, der wirkte intelligent. Er hatte Augen. Augen übrigens ein Punkt, den ein Roboter, also die einen Roboter schlau machen und auch schlau machen sollen. Wenn ein Roboter Augen hat, denkt man direkt, hey, der muss es drauf haben. Wenn er nur ein Auge hat, denkt man vielleicht hat das drauf. Wenn er keine Augen hat, denkt man, was soll das denn sein? 033 177 97 110. Eure Erfahrungen mit Robotern möchten wir gerne hören, egal welcher Art. Und wenn noch so ein Roboter Bauer dran wäre, wären wir natürlich besonders froh. Habtet ihr schon mal ein? Okay, also gut. Frank, ist mal bitte eine Sekunde ruhig. Wir wissen Staubsauger Roboter, der irgendwie alles alleine macht. Schon mal einen Roboter gehabt?
Ähm, hab ich noch gar nicht drüber nachgedacht, um ehrlich zu sein. Hab ich schon mal einen Roboter gehabt? Ich glaube...
Also der einzige Roboter, den ich hatte, ich glaube, ich habe mir mal im Alter von acht oder neun Jahren eingebaut. Der hatte, der war aber komplett aus Holz. Und ich weiß noch, dass ich mir bei dem Teleskoparm die Karten gelegt habe. Also aus Holz einen Teleskoparm zu schnitzen, ist eine echte Herausforderung. Und den habe ich dann, damit er auch metallisch aussah, mit Ofenbranche noch angemalt. Das war eine widerliche Sauerei. Und ja, er sah halt aus wie ein Roboter. Ich wurde damals, glaube ich, inspiriert durch Robby, Tobi und das Flibertüt. So, also schon eine ganze Weile her.
Ja, konnte der auch was oder war das halt nur so ein Modell, so optisch was?
Und der konnte blinken. Also ich glaube, ich habe auch irgendwo eine Birne an den an den Arm gemacht und der konnte blinken und den Arm halt ein und ausfahren mit ein bisschen Hilfe.
Ja, nicht schlecht. Da merkt man mal, wie weit die Technik heutzutage schon fortgeschritten ist.
Link robotisch schlecht.
Was mich aber bei Frank jetzt noch mal interessieren würde, um zu diesem Staubsauger Roboter zurückzukommen. Das ist aber schon eher so ein Ding, wenn das irgendwie so gerade flächensauber macht, auch um deinen Fuß drumherum düngelt und so. Das ist schon auch eher für dein Büro gedacht als für zu Hause für noch mehr Zeug auf dem Fußboden rumstehen und so was.
Naja, also ich hab den auch mal zu Hause getestet und das geht. Wie groß ist denn überhaupt, wie man sich das vorstellt? Das muss man sich so vorstellen, das ist eine ungefähr 40 Zentimeter, vielleicht 45 Zentimeter große Scheibe, die so vielleicht so 15 Zentimeter hoch ist, so runde Ecken an allen Ecken, also runde Kanten. Die Ecken hat es ja keinen, das ist ja rund. Und hat auf einer Seite halt so einen Sensor-Bumper, also wenn man damit irgendwo gegenfährt, merkt man das halt. Und da hat man auch so verschiedene kleine Tüdelchen, mit denen er so unter Kanten durchwuseln kann. Und naja, halt da oben hat er irgendwie so ein paar Tasten drauf. Und da gibt es noch eine Fernbedienung. Und dann gibt es noch so Spielkram, wie zum Beispiel eine Infrarotlichtschranke, mit der man ihn halt von Glasflächen weghalten kann oder von Treppen, die er halt möglicherweise nicht erkennen könnte. Aber das ist halt schon durchaus ein ausgereiftes System, muss man sagen.
Und um wie lange braucht er so?
Zum Saugen, das hängt natürlich von der Raumgröße ab. Also das einzige Problem ist bei dem Ding, dass der Staubbehälter ist noch zu klein. Es gibt jetzt aber noch eine andere Variante, die halt einen dreimal so großen Staubbehälter, weil das war nicht der einzige, der auch immer zu viel Staub auf dem Fußboden hatte. Und den setzt man so hin und saugt dann so eine halbe Stunde in so einem Zimmer, wie das hier, also so vier mal fünf Meter saugt er so eine halbe Stunde vor sich hin und dann ist es sauber. Man kann es halt prima testen, man schnitteln aus dem Aktenvernichter.
Ich kann mir das Büro wirklich lebhaft vorstellen.
Ist toll, wenn die ganze Zeit so eine Schwarzwälder Kirschtrotter durch die Gegend fährt und reinigt.
Also das ist ein Nachteil, man kann nicht wirklich zugegen sein, weil das ist halt ein Staubsauger, das ist halt auch wirklich laut wie ein Staubsauger. Das ist halt so eher so ein Ding so anmachen und mal einen Kaffee trinken.
Ja, aber das ist doch super, dann gehst du morgens aus dem Haus, gehst zur Arbeit, jetzt in dem Fall im Büro ist natürlich blöd, aber machst halt abends nach Ladenschluss quasi und dann macht er im Grunde alles sauber, ist doch geil. Macht er dann auch Schluss irgendwann, checkt er so irgendwie durch?
Nicht schlecht.
Okay, der Sven aus Lichtenberg ist am Telefon, heißt Sven.
Hallo.
Du hast auch schon mal einen Roboter gebaut.
Ich sag mal so, bis vor kurzem ging die Zeitung noch, also das ist jetzt ausgelaufen sozusagen, ist jetzt Ende und das nennt sich Real Robot, das war mal ganz groß draußen gewesen. Da konntest du jede zweite Woche, kam dann eine neue Zeitung raus und da konntest du dann so den zusammen basteln.
Was war das genau für ein Teil, weil wir kennen die Zeitschriften nicht ich zumindest.
Wie soll man sagen, den konntest du programmieren, den konntest du sprachsteuern. Erst konntest du nur, dass er bestimmte Punkte, also so eine Linie nachfolgen konnte. Er hatte unten so einen Fühler, der hatte die Linie immer abgetastet, ist er hinterhergefahren oder dann ging es dann weiter, dann konnte er bestimmte Lichtquellen folgen oder Geräusche. Also immer Stück für Stück konntest du dann ihn aufarbeiten sozusagen. Und dann hast du die Firmium gekriegt dazu, dann konntest du den auch, ja, hast du erst eine Firmium nur eben programmieren können, was auch ziemlich schwer war. Dann gab es dann vier CDs, also am Ende waren es dann vier CDs gewesen und dann konntest du den so programmieren, wie du ihn haben wolltest. Dann kannst du ihm bestimmte, wie soll man sagen, Richtungsfolgen angeben, die er fahren sollte. Also schon richtig cool das Teil.
Und da hast du dann so alle zwei Wochen so eine Zeitung und ein paar Teile bekommen oder wie?
Ja, ja, ja, aber ich muss natürlich sagen, wenn man am Endeffekt dann überlegt, was dir als Spaß insgesamt gekostet hat, dann setzt man sich echt am Kopf. Ja, also ich habe sieben Euro neunzig bezahlt. Das ging jetzt bis zur 72. Ausgabe. Dann kann man sich den Rest ja ausrechnen.
Und was kriegt man denn so für 72 mal 7 Euro neunzig? Also was kann das Ding jetzt am Ende?
Ja, also ich kann das Ding selber steuern.
Ich kann das auch programmieren.
Es kann mir folgen wie so ein Hund im Grunde genommen. Ja, es kann zum Beispiel auch Linien direkt folgen. Es kann nicht Quellen direkt folgen. Ich kann ihm auch sagen, was er direkt machen soll. Das Einzige, was mich noch ein bisschen stört, ist, wie soll man sagen, die Akkuleisten, da muss es noch bessere Akkus geben im Grunde genommen.
Und das hat jetzt...
Aber es kann sich auch selber zum Beispiel aufladen. Der Hammer. Also der fährt dann in seine Ladestation rein, klickt und dann ist Ruhe.
Das finde ich aber noch irgendwie einen vertretbaren Preis, weil so ein Staubsauger, der so eine Ladestation selber findet, kostet so 200 Euro ungefähr.
Ja, ja, nee, ist richtig. Aber ich sag mal so, wenn Sie natürlich überlegen, was man natürlich ganz schön bastelt, und wenn man da nämlich einen Fehler macht, muss man sich den Teil, wo man vielleicht, das ist mir nämlich passiert, da ist mir der, wie sagt man, Kontaktgummi von diesem Display der Fernbedienungsabhandlung gekommen. Ja, und dann heißt das, diese Zeitung nachbestellen. Das dauert dann mal locker vier bis fünf Wochen.
Und geht das noch weiter oder ist das jetzt eigentlich fertig?
Ja, man könnte es noch weiter machen, aber bis jetzt wird das Spiel rein. Sprich, jetzt könntest du mit denen zum Beispiel auch nach Fußball spielen und so ein Schnickschnack. Ja, also kannst du dir ein Tor holen, dann gab es jetzt so einen elektronischen Ball dazu. Den habe ich jetzt auch noch mitgenommen. Ich habe jetzt ein Tor und ein Ball noch mit dazu genommen. Und wenn du Kameraden hättest, die würden auch miteinander kommunizieren. Die Roboter, die würden miteinander kommunizieren. Mit denen könntest du den auch steuern und kannst dann Fußball spielen. Also, das ist absolut der Hammer, das Teil also.
Ja, das klingt doch nach viel Spaß wie wenig Geld im Vergleich.
Ja, ich sag mal so, für wenig Geld, wer es hat, also ich sag mal so, hätte ich das alles mit einmal zahlen müssen, um Gottes Willen, das hätte ich nicht gemacht, garantiert. Aber ich sag mal so, das konnte man sich leisten. Wenn ich mir so andere Sachen angucke, weil die Japaner so produzieren hier ihren gehbaren Robot, der jetzt schon angeblich schneller laufen kann und so. Das kann sich doch keinem beschleißen, nicht mal in 20 Jahren.
Na, da wäre ich mir nicht so sicher, ob das so ist in 20 Jahren.
Ja, ich sag mal so, die Technik ist ja noch nicht so weit ausgereift. Also wenn ich mir das so, ich bin ja so ein Technikfanat, Pekka. Ja, ganz ehrlich. Also ich lüte auch manchmal so ein bisschen was wildes Zeug zusammen, um mal zu gucken, was passiert.
Ja, also das ist nicht so.
Ja gut, aber was hast du vor zehn Jahren zusammen gelötet?
Na, so weit waren wir da noch nicht. Also ich denke mal, da hatte ich die Kenntnisse noch nicht. Also ich sag mal so, vor zehn Jahren wusste ich wie ein Rechner an, und ich wusste wie ein Rechner aussehen. Das war auch schon meine elektronischen Kenntnisse.
Ja du, aber das heißt ja nicht, dass nicht in zehn Jahren die Technik schon so weit ist, dass die Rechner auch sehr, die Roboter sehr erschwinglich werden. Also ehrlich gesagt, rechne ich sogar damit, dass es relativ bald so mal sein wird.
Ja, ich sag mal so, wenn es denn so wäre, dann hätte ja jeder einen. Und da kommt dann schon wieder die Frage auf, wo es auch in vielen Filmen gezeigt wird, wie z.B. ja, auch vielleicht eventuell nicht ein Roboter, auch eine Gefahr darstellen kann.
Also ich muss sagen, ich gebe dir teilweise recht, ich bin eigentlich auch eher hier der Roboter Skeptiker in der Runde, aber am Preis wird es oder an den Kosten wird es wahrscheinlich eher nicht scheitern. Wir haben das mal spaßeshalber durchgerechnet, wie teuer denn ein Roboter sein könnte, der wirklich menschliche Arbeitskraft ersetzt. Und selbst wenn der Roboter nur drei Jahre hält und ja einen unqualifizierten Hilfsarbeiter ersetzt, dann könnte das Gerät schon, wenn er rund um die Uhr sieben Tage die Woche arbeitet, bis zu 300.000 Euro kosten und der Arbeitgeber würde dann trotzdem noch einen Schnitt machen.
180.000.
Genau. 180 waren es für den unqualifizierten Roboter und für etwas für gelernte Fachkräfte, wenn die ersetzt werden, könnte man auch schon Roboter für 300.000 bis 1 Million Euro ungefähr würden sich dort amortisieren.
So viel zum Geld, aber ich glaube auch, dass man muss mal abwägen, als diese, sagt man Automechanerie, diese ersten Computer gesteuerten Roboterarmee kriegt, wie viele Leute sind dabei arbeitslos geworden? Und das muss man dann wieder sozusagen dagegen setzen, um mal zu überlegen, ist es denn das wirklich wert? Wir haben schon so viel Arbeitslose. Da kommen dann die Kosten, jetzt ganz logisch gedacht, die Leute, die durch diesen Roboter arbeitslos werden, weil dieser Roboter ja vielleicht, weiß ich nicht, fünf Sachen mit ihm machen kann, daneben fünf Leute, die sind arbeitslos, und fünf Leute leben von der Sozialhilfe. Das Geld, das muss man damit dazurechnen und wieder abziehen, was er im Grunde genommen mehr verdienen würde.
Aber das sind Kosten der Gesellschaft, nicht des Unternehmens. Für die Unternehmen rechnet sich das halt schon zu den genannten Beträgen und welche Kosten auf uns sozusagen dann in der Folge dazukommen. Das ist die andere Seite der Medaille.
Ja, aber man muss mal überlegen, ist es denn das wirklich wert, andere Leute, die vielleicht qualifiziert wären? Ja, man kann kein Computer oder kein Rechner, ich zum Beispiel bin gelernter Maler und Lackierer. Ganz ehrlich, ich hab drei Jahre lang gelernt, um diesen Beruf zu kommen. Und ich weiß mit einer hundertprozentigen Sicherheit, dass kein Roboter der Welt mich ersetzen kann. Weil wir können nicht erwarten, dass ein Roboter eine Wand, es ist keine Wand genauso wie die andere. Es ist keine Oberfläche genauso wie die andere. Und eher der Rechner das herausgefunden hat. Also ganz ehrlich, da bin ich schon fünfmal fertig.
Meinst du nicht, dass die Leute, die damals Autos lackiert haben, bevor die Roboter kamen und noch selber gesagt haben?
Ja, im Moment, beim Auto, da wird immer eine Karosserie, da machen sie vielleicht 5 Millionen von und die dehnen sich. Immer wieder, immer wieder. Und ich nenne jetzt mal ein Beispiel Plattenbau. Da ist dann zum Beispiel mal die Suge anders. Dann ist da eine Kante drin. Die Wände sind dicht gerade. Und dann ist da oben mal eine Delle drin. Dann schneidet der natürlich, weil er wie er gewohnt ist, die Bahn auf 260 ab, aber die Decke ist nicht mehr 260, die ist 265 und dann kommt er dann.
Also ich möchte dich ja nicht deillusionieren, aber du musst dir einfach mal bewusst machen, dass ein also ein großes Einsatzfeld für Roboter heute schon, also nicht ein theoretischer zukünftiger Markt, sondern etwas, was heute bereits stattfindet, ist militär. Und da fahren diese Maschinen halt über wilde Äcker durch feindliches Gebiet, wo irgendwie Leute hinter lauernden Mauern, hinter Mauern lauern und werden dahin programmiert, mit solchen Situationen umzugehen. Da halte ich die Unebenheit in einer Wand auf die Farbe aufgetragen werden soll noch für ein vergleichsweise triviales Problem. Auch wenn ich dir durchaus zustimme, dass das natürlich erst mal ein Problem ist. Aber ist so ein bisschen wie mit Schachcomputern, weißt du?
Ich finde aber die Frage, ob es tatsächlich die Gesellschaft sich leisten kann, so viele Roboter für Berufe, die heute noch Leute im Lohn und Brot halten, abzustellen. Die Frage finde ich schon sehr berechtigt wichtig, weil letztendlich wird es halt dann dazu führen, dass die Roboter Dinge tun bzw. Wohlstand erwirtschaften, der uns dazu zwingt alle vor der Playstation zu sitzen, weil wir gar nichts anderes mehr zu tun haben.
Das könnten wir uns im Grunde genommen gar nicht mehr leisten. Mal ganz ehrlich gesagt, weil ohne Arbeit kein Geld, ohne Geld kein Wohlstand. Also wenn wir nicht arbeiten gehen würden, weil ja die Roboter das alles machen, das bringt uns ja auch nicht. Verstehen Sie? Das ist nicht möglich. Es ist wie ein Teufelskreis. Denn der eine hat sich das geleistet, du wirst dafür gefeuert. Kannst dir theoretisch ja nicht mal dann deinen Roboter leisten, weil du das Geld nicht mehr hast.
Aber überleg mal, es geht ja auch um andere Konzepte. Stell dir vor, es ist für deinen Staat billiger, dir einen Roboter auszuhändigen, anstatt dir sozusagen deine Sozialhilfe zu bezahlen über die Länge der Zeit. Deswegen gibt der Staat dir den Roboter und der Roboter geht für dich arbeiten.
Ja toll, aber ich sag mal so, was machen Sie denn, wenn der Roboter mal einen Kurzschluss kriegt? Das muss man alles vorher abdenken. Man muss das alles sichern. Ich sag mal so ein kleiner Roboter wie meiner Wenigkeit, was kann da groß passieren? Das Ding rennt in die Wand und dann ist es kaputt.
Also in den 70er und 80er Jahren wurde das Ganze sehr kontrovers und heiß diskutiert. Komischerweise ist das Thema aus der politischen Diskussion in den letzten Jahrzehnten praktisch verschwunden. Die Frage machen uns Roboter arbeitslos. Sie hat sich so still und heimlich rausgeschlichen, aber und wurde am Ende mit Ja beantwortet? Und am Ende wird man das wahrscheinlich nur über eine Steuer lösen können, über eine Robotersteuer oder eine Maschinensteuer, die immer wieder in der Diskussion war, die allerdings natürlich unter Globalisierungsaspekten überhaupt nicht durchsetzbar scheint im Moment. Aber praktisch.
Ich glaube, das wird so eines dieser Themen sein, die uns dann alle plötzlich überraschen. Also stellen wir so vor, 2019, Daimler Kreisler stellt dann endlich den ersten LKW vor, für den man keinen Fernfahrer mehr braucht.
Ja, toll und der nächste ist wieder Arbeit.
Also die nächsten 10.000 oder 20.000 oder 30.000. Und dann nimmt irgendjemand den Taschenrechner in die Hand und stellt fest, naja, das lohnt sich halt schon. Also machen wir das mal. Und letzten Endes wird es darauf hinauslaufen, dass irgendwie der gesellschaftliche Umgang mit solchen Technologien halt irgendwie mal geregelt werden muss an irgendeiner Stelle. Und zwar weltweit.
Ja, ist richtig. Da gibt es dann dieser Faktor Mensch dann nicht mehr. Ja, toll. Da gibt es nur noch der Faktor Computer oder Roboter. Ja, ich sag mal so.
Also nun ist ja Fernfahrer Tätigkeit auch nicht unbedingt gerade ein besonders menschenwürdiger Job.
Es gibt verdammt viele Fernfahrer vor allen Dingen. Ist ja nicht so, als würde es davon so ein paar geben.
Ja.
Also es ist ziemlich schwierig. Ich meine es hat natürlich auch andere Aspekte. Was ist zum Beispiel, wenn wir mal bei diesem Fernfahrerbeispiel bleiben, der elektronische Fernfahrer kann natürlich wie immer wie jeder Roboter 24 Stunden, 7 Tage die Woche das Ganze machen. Er kann in Tunneln unterwegs sein, der Dinger kein Licht ist, weil er muss nicht sehen, weil er macht das Ganze sowieso über Funk. Das sind schon interessante Aspekte. Das würde natürlich auch zum Umwelt schonen. Da macht man den ganzen Interconnect Verkehr, läuft alles unterirdisch ab und man hört davon auch nichts. Und da müssen halt mal so ein paar Tunnelroboter die Tunnel warten. Aber wo soll das mit der Gesellschaft hingehen? Also was ich auch gerne fragen würde jetzt an alle anderen, die vielleicht Fritz hören und sich jetzt auch so ein paar Gedanken darüber machen. Habt ihr da Angst vor, vor dieser Utopie, die wir jetzt hier gerade ausbreiten? Oder sagt ihr, das ist eigentlich, ist es unaufhaltsam, was da kommt? Es passiert einfach. Wir werden diese Roboter irgendwann haben und wir werden irgendwann die Probleme haben, wie in iRobot, du hast den Film ja schon selber angesprochen, hier mit Will Smith. Macht euch doch mal eure Gedanken. Ruft an 033 177 97 110. Macht ihr euch Sorgen, wenn ihr die robotisierte Gesellschaft seht, die wir möglicherweise in 10, 20 Jahren haben?
Ich sag mal, sag mal so ganz ehrlich. Also ich weiß ja nicht, ob ihr auch wirklich nicht Stargate guckt, mal ganz doof gefragt. Einige Leute tun das ja, ich weiß das ja nicht. Also selten gucke ich mir das mal an. Aber da gab es zum Beispiel auch diese bestimmte Folge, wo so eine Art Maschine, so eine Art Metall, sich selbst produzieren konnte. Ja, sich selbst herstellen konnte.
Roboter produzieren Roboter, das passiert heute schon.
Guck mal, was machen wir dann? Irgendwann haben sie einen Übermacht erreicht. Ja, das ist genau das, was ihr jetzt ansprecht. Wir können das ja nicht mehr steuern. Ja toll, das ist genauso, als wenn wir eine Armeenmacht haben, die sich dann irgendwo verkriecht und wir denken, wir haben das abgeschoben, toll, super toll, sind wir los. Aber im Grunde werden die immer mehr. Ja und dann haben wir die Eimerkarte jetzt so.
Sven, bleiben wir mit der Eimerkarte einfach mal zufrieden. Jetzt am Ende deines Vortrags stehen und nehmen das mit für alle anderen Hörer, die heute Abend noch folgen. Ja, vielen Dank für den Anruf.
Ja, du hast es ja gerade gesagt, Max. Das M-Wort hast du gesagt. Matrix. Ja, das ist ja eigentlich, da kommen wir ja wirklich an diesen Punkt, also diese Vision der Machtübernahme der Roboter, also nicht nur Matrix hat das, auch Terminator hat das ganz tief.
Genau, vor 20, 21 Jahren.
Genau, also es ist keine wirklich neue Vision und ich denke, wenn man in Science Fiction Literatur blättert, dann wird man da noch so einige oder andere ähnliche Ideen finden, aber insbesondere bei Matrix ist das stark ausgeprägt, gerade auch in diesem Zusammenhang mit dieser wirtschaftlichen Geschichte. Es gibt ja diese schöne Kollektion, die Animatrix, diese neuen Animated Stories, unterschiedliche Stile, die alle so mit dieser Grundidee des Films Matrix spielen. Da gibt es dann zwei drauf, The Second Renaissance Part 1 und Part 2, wo halt die eigentliche Geschichte, die Hintergrundgeschichte von Matrix, also sozusagen noch vor dem ersten Film abgespielt wird, wo das ja genau drin ist. Die Menschen bauen sich die Roboter, die Roboter übernehmen immer mehr Tätigkeiten. Irgendwann gibt es dann den Aufstand der Menschen und Roboter werden auf den Straßen gejagt und gehetzt und geschlagen und verjagt. Und dann sind die eben ganz böse und werden verbannt, gruppieren sich dann irgendwo in der Wüste und bauen dort ihr 01 Welt auf und übernehmen dann aber wiederum durch ihre maximale Automatisierung Schritt für Schritt die Weltwirtschaft und Geistern sozusagen, die die Menschheit dann nochmal über eine ganz andere Methode, quasi mit ihren eigenen Waffen. Ja, ich hab das nochmal erwähnt, weil das natürlich eins dieser Bilder ist, die wir auch immer mit drin haben, die von daher natürlich hier in dem Kontext auch diskussionswürdig sind.
So ein bisschen schwierigerer Natur heute Abend, weil es nicht einfach nur um eine Frage geht, die ihr vielleicht beantworten könntet oder über die ihr euch Gedanken macht, sondern es geht darum immer direkt einen ganzen Komplex von Bildern euch vorzustellen, was denn da alles so passieren könnte. Deswegen ist es vielleicht nicht einfach. Lasst euch ruhig einen Moment Zeit und überlegt mal einfach für euch, was ihr euch wünscht für die Zukunft. Würdet ihr euch diese Roboterwelt wünschen? Die ganzen Vorteile, die da zu kriegen sind, liegen auf der Hand. Oder habt ihr eben halt auch diese Ängste? 0-3-3-1-7-97-1-1-0 ist die Nummer der Hotline von Fritz. Und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich fahr zum Beispiel, also weil es ist ein Beispiel, was man greifen kann. Deswegen finde ich diesen Saug, Staubsaugeroboter vom Frank so gut. Ich würde mir sowas auch wünschen, weil ich bin ein hoffnungsloser Fall. Ja, und selbst ich alleine mit meinem Staubsauger würde alles kaputt machen. Wahrscheinlich viel eher als so eine Maschine. Aber das ist die Frage. Man kann die Maschine irgendwann mehr. Dann kann sie irgendwann für mich einkaufen, irgendwas bestellen. Es gibt zum Beispiel auch diese neue Vorstellung automatisiertes Heim. Ist ja auch eine Art von Robotik, wenn man so möchte. Dass mein Kühlschrank weiß, was ich im Kühlschrank habe, der weiß, wie viel Kalorien das hat, der weiß, dass meine Zahnpasta alle und so weiter. Wir verlassen uns also immer mehr auf diese ganzen Maschinen. Das tun wir jetzt schon. Also zum Beispiel, wer kennt noch die Telefonnummern seiner Freunde? Kaum einer, weil die alle im Handy sind. Wenn man dann aber das verfluchte Handy nicht mehr anmachen kann, weil es kaputt ist oder die Karte ist im Arsch, ja, da muss man zu seinen ganzen Freunden gehen und wie so ein Blöder fragen, ob die einem nochmal die Nummer geben, weil man sie einfach nicht mehr weiß.
Pack-ups machen.
Ich kann mir immer, ich stell mir das bei Frank immer so vor, wie bei diesem einen Star Trek Kinofilm, dass Frank dann vor seinem Handy steht und davon nur sagt, Pavel, Pavel. Was? Eine Tastatur? Wie rückständig. 0371 77 97 110 die Nummer im Blue Moon. Macht mit beim Talk Chaos Radio heute Abend zum Thema Roboter und die Zukunft. Ihr hört das Chaos Radio, Aufritz. Wir haben es kurz nach 11 und heute Abend Thema beim Chaos Computer Club Aufritz hier im Talk, Roboter. Wir haben die Zukunftswoche und möchten einfach mal so ein bisschen den Blick in die etwas weiter entfernteren Jahre werfen. Unter der Woche ist das Jahr 2015, also wirklich zehn Jahre in der Zukunft. Aber wenn man so hört, was hier heute Abend schon so geredet wird, auch über staubsaugende Roboter und ähnliches, dann könnte man sich schon vorstellen, dass in 10, 20 Jahren die Gesellschaft ein bisschen anders aussieht, weil Roboter einige der Aufgaben erledigen, die da normalerweise anfallen und die wir normalerweise tun. 0373-7797-110 ist die Nummer und wir haben auch schon darüber gesprochen, dass es so ein bisschen so ein Horrorszenario sein könnte, weil wenn es ganz viele Menschen gibt, die durch Roboter ersetzt werden, was machen wir dann noch und wo geht dann irgendwie die Menschheit hin? Vielleicht geht es einfach nur unter. Na, der Marco ist am Telefon aus Wilmersdorf. Hallo Marco.
Ja, also zu der Frage nochmal, die du uns gestellt hast, ob wir uns Gedanken machen über Roboter und so und was später mit uns passieren wird. Also ich hab mir da auch früher Gedanken gemacht darüber und ich hab ehrlich gesagt auch schon ein bisschen irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, Angst. Also ich vertraue den Robotern irgendwie jetzt nicht so richtig.
Also du findest Roboter nicht vertrauenswürdig?
Ja, also ich finde irgendwie, dass nach Zeit irgendwie es auch keine Wälder mehr geben wird und nur noch Industrien und Roboter und alles mögliche und irgendwann kommen die Roboter aus der Kontrolle und dann sind die dran.
Hast du einen Computer?
Ja, hab ich.
Und hast du zu dem Vertrauen?
Ja, zu dem hab ich Vertrauen, der tut dir nichts.
Wo siehst du den Unterschied zwischen deinem Computer und einem Roboter?
Ja, der Roboter bewegt sich und er erfüllt Befehle oder so und denkt ja schon richtig. Das macht der Computer zwar auch, aber er kann jetzt nicht irgendwie Gegenstände nehmen oder irgendwie sich bewegen.
Also du findest es irgendwie kritisch, dass ein Roboter oder so eine Maschine tatsächlich mit der realen Welt interagieren kann und nicht nur sich auf ihre Bits beschränkt?
Ja, also dass der irgendwann mal außer Kontrolle gelangt.
Aber eigentlich gilt das ja auch für deinen Computer, oder? Ich meine, macht sich das jetzt nur daran fest, dass er durch die Gegend marschieren kann? Weil der so, dass der Roboter kann denken, der Computer nicht. Naja, das kann ich nicht ganz so nachvollziehen, weil er letzten Endes ein Roboter auch nichts anderes ist.
Ja, okay, aber der Roboter, der bewegt sich, er macht für Dinge, er kann Gegenstände, er bewegt sich so wie ein normaler Mensch.
Sagen wir es mal so, wenn es um die Interaktion mit der normalen Welt geht, also das, was uns als Menschen so auszeichnet, dass wir das auch tun können, könnte man natürlich sagen, dass wir dem Computer ja immer näher kommen, weil wir machen sowas wie Online-Banking, wir kaufen irgendwelche Bücher online, das heißt unsere Welt wird immer mehr in die Welt der Computer reingezogen, das heißt der Computer kriegt auch immer mehr Macht in dieser Welt.
Also ist ja auch dann ein bisschen bedenklich fast schon.
Ja, also das hat ja glaube ich auch in Amerika angefangen, mit diesen Manufakturen oder so, glaube ich. Und das war am Beginn glaube ich des 20. Jahrhunderts und dadurch entstanden die ganzen Roboter, Teile die an Autos und anderes entworfen oder entwickelt haben. Und von Zeit zu Zeit wurde das eben halt immer größer. Und jetzt gibt es schon also bald, also in China zumindest auch, schon Roboter, die jetzt so für uns real sind, die sich bewegen, die was machen. Und den sollte man nicht so vertrauen so. Weil ich glaube den Bürgern, also nicht den Bürgern, dem Staat geht es nur darum zu sparen, viel mehr Dinge, weil Roboter arbeitet schneller als Mensch. Der macht das alles ganz viel genau. Und der macht alles ganz schnell und erledigt das schneller. Also der Staat will sich damit auch ein bisschen Schnelligkeit fördern, weißt du? Und davon habe ich irgendwie jetzt später mal Angst.
Okay, dann nehmen wir die Angst mal so mit und mal sehen, was die anderen hören dazu zu sagen. Dank dir, Marco. Der Max ist noch am Telefon.
Und zwar wollte ich einmal noch wegen der Zukunft, Zukunftsangst und so weiter nochmal das Thema Arbeitsplätze ansprechen, weil ich ja glaube, dass es doch so ein primäres Problem ist. Und zwar, wenn jetzt die Unternehmer, die haben ja hauptsächlich so die Computer oder die Roboter und dadurch wird ja das Geld im Prinzip so immer weiter auf bestimmte Positionen zentriert, so wie es halt irgendwie bisher ja auch schon der Fall war. Aber die Arbeitsplätze, es gibt ja trotzdem noch viele Arbeitsplätze, die erhalten bleiben und zwar die in der Entwicklung, weil ich nicht glaube, dass Roboter es in näherer Zukunft schaffen werden, selber keine Ahnung, die Ideen haben sie jedenfalls nicht dafür. Da reicht glaube ich die künstliche Intelligenz nicht für aus. Gerade die ist ja auch, die die wir jetzt haben eigentlich nur noch vom Menschen programmiert, also es ist ja keine wirkliche künstliche Intelligenz.
Was für Aufgaben könnte das sein, wo du dir dann den Menschen letztendlich vorstellst, wo dominiert er dann?
Also ganz banal könnte man jetzt die Computerspiele mal ansprechen. Also diese ganze Kreativität, die haben Computer einfach nicht. Ob es jetzt um Künstler im Allgemeinen geht oder so oder überhaupt die Idee dafür haben, dass ein Computer irgendeine bestimmte Arbeit übernehmen könnte.
Also du meinst, dass eine zunehmende Automatisierung, Roboterisierung dazu führt, dass sich die Tätigkeiten, sagen wir mal, mir in Denkrichtung verlagern, also das, was schon als Knowledge Economy bezeichnet wird. Aber glaubst du denn, dass genügend Leute daran wirklich beschäftigt werden können beziehungsweise auch über die Fähigkeiten verfügen, da beschäftigt zu werden?
Ja, ich glaube, genau da liegt das Problem, weil es ja auch schon, es gibt ja schon genug Leute, die vielleicht, naja das klingt jetzt böse, aber deren Intellekt ja wahrscheinlich auch vielleicht nicht dafür ausreicht, um irgendwie so, ja sich so viel auszudenken. Und viele haben ja auch nicht die Muße, um irgendwie jetzt, ja, kommen halt nicht auf die Ideen.
Aber eigentlich, also für mich klingt das Ganze wie eine schöne Vision. So die Roboter machen die Arbeit und wir werden alle Künstler. Und als Künstler braucht man eigentlich auch nicht jetzt einen besonders herausragenden Intellekt zu haben, also Künstler.
Roboter da gut zu geeignet sind, sich da so die ganze Infrastruktur von selbst auszudenken.
Na gut, aber ich meine, also sagen wir mal, es ist doch eigentlich eine positive Vision zu sagen, okay, die einfachen Tätigkeiten, die halt gut zu automatisieren und robotisieren sind, die werden halt automatisiert und robotisiert. Und die Tätigkeiten, die eigentlich Spaß machen, sich Sachen ausdenken und so weiter und so fort, die werden halt, bleiben halt übrig.
Oder handeln auf Ebay.
Genau, handeln auf Ebay zum Beispiel. Was ich aber glaube, ist, dass es durchaus einen größeren Teilbereich an Jobs geben wird, die sich um die Roboter kümmern, nämlich Roboter reparieren, Roboter überwachen, Rechtsanwälte, die sich mit den ganzen juristischen Problemen, die durch Roboter entstehen, auseinandersetzen.
Psychologische Betreuung für Roboter.
Genau und Spieleprogrammierung für all die ganzen Leute, die dann keinen Job mehr haben.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Und Roboter spielt um die Jungs bei Launitzer.
Das waren jetzt die Rechtsanwälten, die sie angesprochen haben. Ein Robot wurde ja vorhin mal ganz kurz angesprochen. Ich persönlich finde den Film ja ziemlich flach, aber da wurde das mit dem, was Roboter denn für Rechte haben, ja auch angesprochen, also dass ein Roboter eigentlich gar kein Mord begehen kann und so weiter.
Also mit den Rechtsanwälten, die wird es wahrscheinlich wirklich geben.
Wir hatten ja das schöne Beispiel mit dem Haustier. Also wenn man heute einen Hund hat und naja, ich laufe jetzt mit meinem Hund durch die Straße und du kommst vorbei und der beißt dich.
Oder er rennt über die Straße und das Auto muss ausweichen.
Irgendwas passiert infolge des Hundes. So dann, naja, damit ich als Halter zunächst einmal haftbar und brauche halt irgendwie ein Hund Bau keine scheiße Versicherung und dann teilt halt diese Versicherung. Derzeit gibt es so etwas für Roboter meines Wissens nicht.
Nee, aber was Vergleichbares könnte es also für Autos gibt es ja oder generell für eine ganze Reihe von technischen Geräten. Da geht man davon aus, dass von denen eine Betriebsgefahr ausgeht. Selbst wenn man nicht schuld ist, so sind die Dinger von sich aus gefährlich und können halt böse Dinge tun, also ohne dass man sich schuldhaft verhält. Roboterhaftpflicht für sich auch. Ja genau, das ist dann die Roboterhaftpflicht.
Wir wissen schon mal, dass die Dinger Nummernschilder haben werden. Das wird sich schlicht nicht vermeiden lassen, die Dinger werden einfach Nummernschilder haben, weil sonst ist es ja mit der Haftpflicht ein bisschen schwierig.
Ich hätte dann gerne mal Ihren Ausweis und Ihre Roboterbetriebserlaubnis wieder.
Ja, beim Auto ist es ja schon so, dass es direkt vom Menschen gesteuert wird. Und wenn man jetzt einen Roboter besitzt, der sagen wir mal jetzt noch vorgegaukelte künstliche Intelligenz hat, dem man also nur so ein Befehl gibt, aber die Ausführung bleibt ja dann trotzdem den Roboter überlassen. Und da hat man dann ja nicht die direkte Kontrolle über ihn.
Ja, beim Smart ist das ja auch schon nicht mehr so direkt.
Oder zum Beispiel beim Airbus.
Oder beim Airbus. Also die Grenzen verschwimmen da. Natürlich geht man natürlich davon aus, dass man irgendwie diesem Roboter irgendwas sagt und dann tut er das und dann kann er das aber einfach trotzdem falsch tun. Weil letzten Endes wird zumindest für absehbare Zeit die Software dieser Roboter von Menschen produziert worden sein.
Genau ich sage meinem Roboter überfalle jetzt da drüben die nächste Bank. Aber bitte keine Gewalt. Und der ballert dann trotzdem los, weil er nervös wird. Und ja, so was meinst du?
Ja, dann stehst du vor Gericht und sagst, ich hab ihm gesagt, der soll keinen erschießen, ich bin nicht schuldig.
Genau.
Entschuldigung, wir sind dir jetzt ein bisschen die Parade gefahren.
Bei iRobot, da habe ich noch mal eine Frage.
Ich weiß nicht, habt ihr den Film auch alle gesehen?
Ja, wir kennen ihn alle.
Okay, diese Roboter, die neuen, die wurden ja irgendwie da so ausgeliefert und jeder hat einen bekommen.
Wie wurden die denn bezahlt?
Gute Frage. Vielleicht ist das ja auch schon so ein Teil der Zukunfts Sozialhilfe. Ja, also vorhin kam ja auch so dieses auf, wo ich ja auch wirklich, ich sag das gleich noch mal dazu, ein tolles Verständnis dafür habe, wenn man sagt, die Computer nehmen uns die Arbeitsplätze weg. Entschuldigung, nicht die Computer, sondern die Roboter nehmen uns die Arbeitsplätze weg. Also die Roboter verhindern, dass ich 16 Stunden lang mit dem LKW durch die Gegend fahre. Das sind nun wirklich Jobs, ich würde ihn mir so nicht wünschen. Vielleicht gibt es Leute, die das mit Spaß betreiben, aber es ist sicherlich jetzt nicht unbedingt ein Traumjob, wenn man irgendwie die Wahl hätte zwischen Cocktails, Shaken am Strand und Fernfahrer sein, dann ist das sicherlich eine einfache Entscheidung. Von daher ist es eben nicht unbedingt etwas, was man nicht vielleicht auch weggenommen haben möchte. Wenn man tatsächlich Technik zum Einsatz bringt und es bringt etwas und bestimmte Dinge tun sich dann eben auch so billig, dass sie in der Allgemeinheit billiger bereitgestellt werden kann und kann es ja auch, kann es auch zu einem System führen, in dem dieser Luxus, den wir uns ja gerne leisten wollen, ich meine den gesamten Luxus, jetzt nicht Rolex und Viagra Pillen, sondern der Luxus einfach.
Lebensgefühl.
Ja, Lebensgefühl, sicher sauber leben, tra la la, keine grundsätzlichen Probleme, Krankheiten und so weiter. Das liegt ja auch heute schon zu einem großen Teil an der Technik, die wir haben. Auch den Beruf des Fernfahrers gäbe es eben nicht ohne.
Robert war ja das Ganze wahrscheinlich schon so weit, dass die meisten Menschen wirklich keinen vernünftigen Arbeitsplatz mehr hatten.
Genau.
Und dann ist es nämlich der Familie, die hatte auch noch so einen Roboter bekommen.
Und ich meine, wenn die Eltern beide arbeitslos sind, da können sie sich doch wohl noch gerade um ihr Kind kümmern. Da brauchen sie ja nicht noch einen Roboter, wie ich bitte.
Nein, in Japan die Business Cases für die für die Androiden sehen halt vor allem die Altenpflege als einen wichtigen Business Case, wo eben der Roboter ja für alte Menschen dann Besorgung macht, zum Bäcker geht beispielsweise oder die Wohnung in in Schuss hält. Das sind ganz konkrete Planungen dort und es dürfte vermutlich sogar preiswerter werden, den Menschen einfach einen Roboter zur Verfügung zu stellen als eine Pflegekraft. Ab einem bestimmten Punkt.
Ja, da ist es wahrscheinlich auch wirklich sinnvoll und lohnt es, obwohl ich glaube, ich kenne keinen Menschen, der den Job wirklich gerne macht.
Vor allen Dingen muss man sagen, dass es natürlich billiger ist, aber der Roboter kann natürlich nicht Trost spenden oder mal nett sein oder so. Der hebt dich halt aufs Klo, ist auch dann schön gemacht.
Also sollte das nicht können. Natürlich muss ein Roboter Empathie simulieren können, wenn er in der Altenpflege tätig ist.
Ja, also ich meine, das ist doch gerade seine Hauptanwendung. Das basiert ja darauf, dass du dich quasi um dieses Gerät kümmerst. Das ist ja der alte Trick. Du kümmerst dich quasi um dieses minderwertige Gerät in dem Fall, was dann in dem so quasi Leben simuliert. Nur wenn dir etwas suggerieren soll, es wäre quasi freundlich zu dir, kümmert sich um dich. Ich glaube, das ist um einige schwierige.
Na es gibt also was die Japaner zum Beispiel mit ausgedacht haben, ist, dass Leute, die sich selber nicht mehr aus ihrem Haus bewegen können, aber tatsächlich die, sagen wir menschlichen Funktion einer so Roboter, das in jemand anderes Haus übernehmen. Das heißt also, dass du tatsächlich über den Roboter direkt mit deinem Freund redest und der tatsächlich in der Lage ist, nett zu dir zu sein, indem er halt einfach auch dahinter ein Mensch steckt. Also meine, die Dinger haben ja ein Netz. Das ist ja nicht so, dass das irgendwie eine isolierte Maschine ist, die irgendwie keinen Kontakt zu außen hat.
Lass uns doch mal eine Verschwörungstheorie aufmachen. Ich behaupte, dass alle Hunde, die kleiner als ein Meter sind, bereits heute Roboter sind. Wenn man sich diese Maschinen anschaut, wie die so funktionieren, die haben irgendwie total eingefahrene Sozialverhalten, vollkommen domestiziert, irgendwie hechnen die ganze Zeit mit der Zunge, gucken einem mit großen Augen an, jaulen und japsen und wollen irgendwie was zu essen haben und so. Also sie haben voll dieses Tamagotchi-Verhalten und die Dinger werden massenhaft gekauft.
Sie werden ausspionieren, wie wir Menschen uns verhalten und irgendwann dann später die Weltherrschaft übernehmen.
Genau und die haben auch so ein eingebautes Verfallsdatum und so weiter, so dass regelmäßig welche neu nachgekauft werden müssen, so mit Reproduktionssimulationen und so.
Die hinterlassen diese braunen Sonden auf den Bürgerstein.
Ja, also ich wollte jetzt gar nicht immer so ein Überwachungsthema machen, aber wo du gerade sagst, dass dieser Tamagotchi-Effekt wäre jetzt nichts, was die Leute nicht haben wollen. Ich glaube sogar, dass also gerade bei älteren Menschen spielt natürlich ein Haustier auch häufig eine ganz wichtige soziale Rolle, weil das einfach jemand ist, der da ist, um den man sich kümmern kann. Also es geht ja gar nicht mehr nur darum, dass dieses Gerät sich um mich kümmert. Ist natürlich ganz praktisch für bestimmte Sachen, gar keine Frage. Aber man will auch etwas haben, worum man sich kümmern kann.
Ja, vielleicht geht es im Endeffekt ab einem bestimmten Punkt auch nur noch um eine Reaktion. Also wenn so ein Ding 100 Reaktionen drauf hat zwischen ah, oh, hm, Freude und so, dann reicht einem das wahrscheinlich auch schon, weil sonst passiert nämlich überhaupt nichts.
Was war denn der erste populäre Roboter, der verkauft wurde?
Das kann man vielleicht auch nicht irgendwie ersetzen, weil also keine Ahnung, wenn jetzt ein älterer Mensch irgendwie Kontakt sucht und so und hat da so eine Maschine, die sich vielleicht auch noch selber an eine Steckdose anschließt, dann braucht man sich darum schon mal erstens nicht mehr zu kümmern und so eine richtige Zuneigung, weiß ich nicht, ob so ein weicher Körper mit weichem Fell, keine Ahnung, irgendwie und das Schnurren macht wahrscheinlich eine echte Katze doch noch was.
Na ja, es gibt auch Vibratoren.
Also ich mein, der erste populäre Roboter war halt ein Aibo. Muss man auch mal dran denken, ein simuliertes Haustier.
Also der Aibo, ein Hund war es ja, genau.
Genau, also das war sozusagen das, wo Sonja als erstes, wie auch immer, einen kleinen Markt gesehen hat, um da halt reinzugehen. Leute, die halt einen Hund haben wollen, die ja nicht in die Ecke kacken.
Mit großen Augen, mit einem Ohrenwedeln, mit einem Schwanz.
Niedliche Geräusche machen.
Aber willst du, dass dir so ein Hund ins Bett hilft, wenn du halt 81 Jahre alt bist?
Aber der wohnt in der Silber und hat die Gens.
Ja gut, okay. Aber ich meine, das ist halt so erste Generation so. Ich meine, denk einfach dran, wir haben jetzt einfach mal 30 Jahre Entwicklung für uns. Und bis dahin werden diese Roboter halt auch einfach echt scheiße nett sein. Ich meine, guck dir an, was die Japaner machen hier. So diese Asimon, wie sie alle heißen, die sind halt einfach schon cute aus. Die haben große rollende Augen und grinsen und wackeln und sind nett zu dir, oder?
Ja, die wissen auch eine Menge, die können ja eine Menge erzählen. Die können ja für dich in der Wikipedia nachschlagen. Also das ist schon durchaus praktisch. Also wenn ich so einen Asimon so jetzt hier so auf Zuruf hätte und so, der könnte mir jetzt mal irgendwie losgehen, mir noch mal eine Mate holen, weil die wird langsam alle.
Guten Morgen Tim, ich kann dir dein neues Linux installieren.
Aber um nochmal auf welchen, um nochmal von dem Thema wegzukommen, ich wollte nochmal auf die Preise ansprechen von Computertechnologie. Also in der Zeit, die ich jetzt so wirklich wahrgenommen hab, also was jetzt Handys angeht oder die Computer-Abwechslung, Home-PC, da war ja irgendwie von den Handys, das erste Handy von mir war ein Alcatel, ich glaub da hab ich so 80 Mark oder so für bezahlt. Und wenn ich mir heute ein Handy kaufen will, was ja natürlich mehr Funktion hat und so weiter, dann bezahle ich dafür, wenn ich es jetzt nur mit einer Pre-Value-Card kaufen würde, schon mehrere hundert Euro, wenn man will.
Du kannst doch einen Euro bezahlen.
Aber das ist unverhältnismäßig, weil ursprünglich die Entwicklung von dem Handy, dass man erst mal darauf gekommen ist, das mobil zu machen, die Entwicklung hat wahrscheinlich viel, viel mehr gekostet, als heute da eine Kamera reinzusetzen. Und dass dann die Preise immer noch weiter steigen, finde ich schon ziemlich hammer.
Also ich finde nicht, dass die Preise steigen. Also mein erstes Mobiltelefon hat 3500 DM gekostet. So, und das war noch ein Zehnerzgerät. Pocky, genau.
Und ich brauchte ein extra Zimmer dafür.
Und mein jetziges Telefon hat genau einen Euro gekostet. Na so ist es aber, dass die Entwicklung, also ich meine, was wir jetzt sehen, ist halt der Versuch, artificiell die Preise ein bisschen hochzutreiben im Mobiltelefonmarkt, weil die Operator halt noch irgendwas verdienen wollen. Aber prinzipiell ist es schon so, dass die Technologieentwicklung hin zu radikalen niedrigeren Preisen einfach nicht aufzahlt.
Die Subventionen fallen weg.
Aber Roboter dürften eher mit Automobilen und deren Preisen zu vergleichen sein als mit Konsumerelektronik.
Das ist richtig.
Ja, ich glaube, dass in der Technologie doch die private Nutzung da irgendwie auch ziemlich weit vorne steht.
Was meinst du damit genau?
Also, wenn ich jetzt nur auf den PC anspringen soll, also ich weiß nicht, die Hardware hab ich so das Gefühl, jedenfalls seitdem ich irgendwie mit Computern zu tun hab, ist auch extrem teuer geworden. Also wenn ich mir jetzt einen Prozessor kaufen will, da kostet der Beste auf dem Markt 1000 Euro, während das vor zwei, drei Jahren war es jedenfalls nicht so.
Ja, für 1000 Euro kriegst du heute aber auch 150 Millionen Transistoren. Und damals waren das vor 20 Jahren gerade mal publige 40.000.
Ja, aber da war es auch die neueste Entwicklung.
Also ich glaube, wir können dein Argument nicht so ganz nachvollziehen. Wenn ich überlege, ich hab mir gerade einen Computer gekauft für 500 Euro, da ist einfach mal genau alles drin. Der macht alles, was ich will. Der erste Computer, der ich mir gekauft habe, der zu dem damaligen Zeitpunkt alles gemacht hat, was ich will, hat mich 5000 Mark gekostet.
Also es ist schwer belegbar, dass die Computer immer teurer werden.
Ja, ich kann nur als von meinen Verhältnissen sagen.
Also was ich mir vorstellen kann ist, dass die Konsumenten sich daran gewöhnt haben, dass es diese Produkte so gibt. Das heißt, es gibt auch Luxusprodukte in diesem Segment. Früher gab es die einfach nicht. Früher waren GeekTools da. Die hatten dann bestimmt einen Preis mehr, hat keiner bezahlt. Mittlerweile gibt es Luxusprodukte, bezahlst du Designpreise. Du bezahlst irgendwelche, da ist schon Brennerdin Preise, da ist irgendwelche Cardreader Scheiße drin. Irgendwie alles, alles ist drin. Und du kannst es auch irgendwie in der Ferrari-Variante haben. Deswegen sind die Sachen dann im High-End-Preissegment teurer. Es gibt Gamercomputer und so weiter, kenn ich auch alles. Aber im Endeffekt sind die billigen Computer billiger geworden. Das ist glaube ich so. Aber Max, es sind ganz viele verschiedene Sachen. Deswegen danke erst mal für deine Meinung und für die Geschichte, die uns erzählt ist. Ciao. So, Constanze ist am Telefon aus Lichtenberg.
Guten Abend.
Ich will gerne mal zurück auf das Thema Arbeitswelt und Abschaffung der Arbeit. Ich finde auch, dass die bisherigen Anrufer doch relativ negativ gesehen haben. Also diese Art von gesellschaftlicher Utopie, die mit technischen Lösungen irgendwie künstliche Sklaven erzeugt, irgendwelche Androiden Helfer, die einem alles abnehmen. Und ich finde es interessant, woher das Wort kommt. Das Wort, ich habe das schon angesprochen von dem Karol Czapik, das Wort Roboter bedeutet im tschechischen frohen Arbeit. Und das Wort ist also zu sagen als Lebenswort in fast aller Sprachen übergegangen. Also hier sozusagen diese Sklavische schon enthalten. Und ich denke, dass eigentlich diese Angst oder die Angst vor dem Scheitern, dieses Experiments viel aus dem Filmbereich kommt. Fängt eigentlich schon an 1926 mit Fritz Lang und seinem Metropolis, der eigentlich ein Roboterthema, eine Variante des Roboterthemas hat. Oder mit Asimov oder mit, na Frankenstein kennen wir ja auch noch. Also ich glaube, das ist eine ziemlich unbegründete Angst. Und ich fand noch interessant, ich hab grad gelesen, dass bereits in den 80er Jahren einige Berichte über Industrieroboter und deren Auswirkungen auf Arbeitsplätze erstellt wurden, und zwar für den Club of Moom. Und damals war die Berechnung derart, dass so ein Industrieroboter im Schnitt 39 Arbeitsplätze vernichtet, jedoch sieben neue erschafft und zwar qualifizierte Arbeitsplätze. Das fand ich noch interessant und im Übrigen, ich hab noch was interessantes, wenn du das hören willst, und zwar es gibt lustigerweise eine Isonorm, was ein Industrieroboter eigentlich ist. Ein amerikanischer.
Hol doch mal los.
Und zwar, ich zitiere, ein Industrieroboter ist ein automatisches, servokontrolliertes, wiederholt programmierbares, multifunktionales Handhabungsgerät mit mehreren Bewegungsachsen, dass Werkstücke, Teile, Werkzeuge oder andere spezielle Geräte durch variable, programmierte Bewegungsabläufer transportieren kann und eine Vielzahl von Aufgaben überleben kann.
Aber was glaubst du denn, was mit den anderen 32 Leuten passiert?
Na ja, nun die Studie ist natürlich ein bisschen älter. Ich denke, so kann man es heute nicht mehr sehen. Aber es ist dieselbe Debatte, die wir mit der Computisierung oder generell mit einer Maschinisierung führen. Ich denke eigentlich, es wird eine positive Utopie. Im Grunde genommen wollen wir doch alle unsere Arbeit loswerden. Jedenfalls wie die keiner gerne macht.
Und lieber an den Strand gehen.
Genau, ich fand damals dieses, erinnert ihr euch noch an das Wahlplakat der SPD, wo drauf stand Arbeit, Arbeit, Arbeit? Das fand ich nun alles andere als attraktiv.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, so der Zeitgeist heute.
Na gut, es ist halt so, eigentlich will man ja nicht arbeiten, sondern man will leben.
Geld, Geld, Geld, hättest du da drauf?
Ja, ich brauch noch nicht mal Geld. Also wenn ich irgendwie leben kann, auch ohne Geld, dann nehm ich das auch gerne und das wäre für mich durchaus eine positive Vision.
Ist das nicht diese Star Trek Philosophie, kein Geld mehr? Essen kann für jeden so in allen rauen Mengen erstellt werden. Im Grunde kannst du alles machen, wie du das möchtest. Ich meine, alle Roboter die Arbeit machen.
Ja, also klar, das fände ich wirklich eine sehr positive.
Okay, aber die Gesellschaft müsste sich dann sozusagen die Arbeitslosen leisten, also die Gesellschaft müsste in der Lage sein, sagen über ein Bürgergeld oder ähnliche Dinge, die Leute, die nicht arbeiten, zu finanzieren. Also wie auch immer die sozusagen ihren Grundbedarf gesichert bekommen, der muss halt irgendwie her. Und so wie das halt momentan funktioniert in unserer Gesellschaft mit irgendwie Anrechnungszeiten und Einzahlungen, irgendwelche Versicherungen und so weiter und so fort und noch Beschäftigung von einigen 100.000 Arbeitsamtbürokraten, das kann ja ganz offensichtlich nicht der Weg sein, mit dieser Technologie umzugehen. Der einzige Weg, der dann denkbar wäre, wäre zu sagen, okay, wir machen jetzt halt mal einen Kommunismus mit kapitalistischen Mitteln. Das heißt, jeder kriegt seine Grundversorgung gesichert und man arbeitet nur, wenn man halt mehr braucht. Das wäre eigentlich der Weg.
Oder man arbeitet zum Spaß, weil man Lust hat.
Oder man lässt arbeiten.
Richtig ist, das ist halt wirklich alt zurück, eigentlich geht das sogar auf die Bibel zurück. Und ich weiß nicht, ob ihr die kennt, die jüdische Golem-Sage. Der Golem, der Diener und Beschützer war, eine Synagoge, kennt ihr das? Und offensichtlich haben sich da schon zu Uhrzeiten die Menschen dauernd Gedanken gemacht, wie sie den Kram loswerden können. Und ich denke, deshalb muss man es positiv sehen. Man möchte doch eigentlich nicht einfache Arbeiten machen, wenn es doch jemand oder eine Maschine, einen Roboter machen kann.
Okay, man muss halt tatsächlich einen Weg finden, das Sozialumfeld Arbeit, was für viele Leute sehr wichtig ist, zu ersetzen. Es gab ja gerade diese hübsche Studie, wo sie dann doch mal festgestellt haben, dass es eigentlich nicht ums Geld geht, sondern ums Wohlfühlen und dass mehr Geld halt nicht zwingend zu mehr Wohlfühlen führt. Das heißt, es muss halt einfach in den nächsten Jahren, müssen Wege gefunden werden, dieses Wohlfühlen ohne Geld zu erzeugen. Es spricht also, Aufgaben zu geben, die Leute sozial zu integrieren, die halt einfach nicht in der Lage sind, sagen wir mal, diese Knowledge-Ekonomie halt als Arbeitnehmer zu erfüllen zu stehen.
Diese Ein-Euro-Jobs zum Beispiel.
Also weil sie sich auch über Arbeit definieren. Weil das Wichtigste ist, was wir kennen.
Weil die Gesellschaft natürlich auch die Leute über die Arbeit definiert. Also du bist, was du schaffst und wenn du nicht schaffst, bist du nix. Das ist in allen Köpfen drin und sicherlich ein Hemmnis an der Stelle.
Ja, auch ein philosophisches Problem.
Okay, ich würde auch nicht weiter schlafen, sondern gerne noch andere Meinungen hören.
Alles klar, danke Constanze.
Vielen Dank.
Ihr könnt weiter anrufen, 031 77 97 110. Wenn ihr euch bei diesem ethischen bzw. auch philosophischen Problem beteiligen möchtet, an Fragen vielleicht zu dem Thema habt oder selber beisteuern möchtet, dann ruft einfach an. Und wir machen jetzt eben kurz Nachrichten.
Wenn Fritz in der Friednis, dann 103, 1.
Wir haben es 23.32. Mit dem Wetter natürlich. In der Nacht fällt stellenweise Schnee. Es kann glatt werden bei minus 1 bis minus 4 Grad. Morgen soll es meist bewölkt sein. Ab und zu kann es weiter Schnee geben bei maximal 1 Grad.
Die gesetzlichen Krankenkassen haben das vergangene Jahr mit einem Millionenüberschuss abgeschlossen. Mehrere große Kassen gaben heute ihre Zahlen für das Jahr 2004 bekannt. Die deutsche Angestelltenkrankenkasse zum Beispiel hat ein Plus von 365 Millionen Euro verzeichnet. Sie erwägt nun für ihre versicherten Mitte des Jahres, die Beiträge über die gesetzlich geforderten 0, 9 Prozentpunkte hinaus zu senken. In der Affäre um massenhaften Visa Missbrauch steht Bundesaußenminister Fischer weiter unter Druck. Es geht vor allem um die Frage, wann Fischer welche Details erfahren hat. Nach Medienberichten wusste das Auswärtige Amt bereits im Sommer 2002 von Missständen an der Botschaft in Kiew. Unklar blieb heute, inwieweit diese Warnungen Fischer erreichten. Verbraucherschützer haben die geplanten neuen Tarife der Telekom als zu unübersichtlich kritisiert. Kunden müssten ihren Bedarf ganz genau prüfen. Die Telekom hatte angekündigt, dass Telefonieren im Festnetz ab März billiger wird. Das Unternehmen verspricht den Kunden bis zu 75 Prozent Einsparungen im City-Bereich und 59 Prozent weniger Kosten bei Ferngesprächen. In der dritten Runde des UEFA Pokals hat Schalke 04 bei Schacht-Jörd Donetsk mit 1 zu 1 unentschieden gespielt. Der FC Parma und der VfB Stuttgart trennten sich 0 zu 0 unentschieden. Und im Kampf um den deutschen Basketball-Pokal steht Alba Berlin im Viertelfinale, die Berliner gewann, 164 zu 60 beim Zweitligisten Röndorf im Achtelfinale. Der Verkehr Fritz, keine aktuellen Meldungen zurzeit.
Gute Fahrt.
2015, 2015.
Fritz blickt diese Woche in die Zukunft. Wie sieht 2015 aus mit Arbeit, Bildung, Umwelt, Technik und dem ganz alltäglichen Alltag? Wo werdet ihr sein? Was werdet ihr machen? Wie stellt ihr euch die Zukunft vor?
Fritz 2015.
Wie wird's in 10 Jahren sein? Man weiß es nicht. Aber man kann ja mal drüber nachdenken.
In dieser Woche.
Und im Radio.
Er wird schon geschnauft. Das ist der Tim. Daneben sitzt der Pawel und dann noch ein Stückchen weiter links der Frank. Meine Person Max von Malotki. Chaos Computer Club heute Abend zu Gast. Chaos Radio. Ein bisschen über die Halbzeit sind wir, das heißt noch knapp anderthalb Stunden wird hier getalkt zum Thema Roboter am heutigen Abend und Robotik, denn es ist die Zukunftswoche auf Fritz. Und wir haben schon eine Menge mit euch gequatscht, auch über so Risiken und die ganzen ethisch moralischen Hintergründe, die da irgendwie hochkochen, wenn man sich darüber unterhält. Und am Telefon ist der David aus Thüringen. Ihr könnt genauso anrufen unter 0331 77 97 1 1 0 und euch zum Thema aussprechen. Tag David.
Mir geht es also im Grunde genommen eigentlich nur um die Sicherheit dieser Roboter. Ich meine, wenn man das mal in einer näheren Zukunft betrachtet, ich meine so ein Roboter steht ja letzten Endes auch nur aus einem Computer, der sich bewegt, wenn man es jetzt mal ganz böse sieht. Und irgendwo muss ja auch eine Software laufen, die irgendwo mal ein Mensch programmiert hat und jeder Mensch macht da sicher auch Fehler und es gibt auch andere Menschen, die sowas nicht sehen wollen oder nicht sehen wollen, aus irgendeinem Grund und es gibt ja auch sicherheitsrisiken von diesen Robotern, weil ich meine die Roboter müssen ja auch irgendwie untereinander kommunizieren, sag ich jetzt mal. Wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel ein Netzwerk aufbaut, ich sag nur mal Fußballspiel, wie das sehr oft unter Robotern manchmal veranstaltet wird, unter solchen Entwicklern von Robotern und das gibt ja sicher auch Sicherheitsrisiken, weil ihr es wohl auch schön von Angst hattet. Ich meine, es ist ja auch ein Thema, was man ansprechen muss. Schließlich, wenn man heutzutage sieht, Sicherheitsrisiken über WLAN zum Beispiel, die Roboter verständigen sich ja auch über so eine Technologie, jedenfalls in näherer Zukunft, sag ich mal. Und dann könnte es ja auch in der Richtung passieren, dass der Roboter manipuliert wird, ich sag mal, und dann dem Menschen vielleicht böse Dinge tun will, wenn man es jetzt mal böse ausdrückt.
Da hast du in der Tat ein interessantes Thema angesprochen. Also die Betätigungsmöglichkeiten für Hacker erweitern sich natürlich in jeder Hinsicht. Also wenn man bis wenn heute so die härteste Waffe vielleicht so ein Distributed Denial of Service Attack ist, den man von seinem Rechner aus fahren kann, da bekommt dann sicherlich mit Robotern, wenn man wenn man so eine Horde Roboter, ein paar hundert oder ein paar tausend Roboter plötzlich unter seiner Kontrolle hat das Wort Angriff eine ganz andere Bedeutung.
Oder wenn du halt hingehst und so was wie eine vorautomatische Fabrik durch so einen Angriff, einfach mal durch einen elektronischen Angriff unter deine Kontrolle bringen kannst, das macht diese natürlich auch noch wesentlich faszinierender, weil dann legst du nicht nur halt eine Webseite lahm, sondern halt tatsächlich ein richtiges großes System. Ja, ich meine, das wird halt wie mit Flugzeugen sein. So ein Airbus zum Beispiel, da sind halt drei verschiedene Computer drin, wo die Software von zwei oder drei verschiedenen Teams geschrieben ist, die dieselbe Funktionalität macht, um halt auszuschließen, dass die beide dieselben systematischen Fehler machen. Und ich denke mal, Roboter, die sich im öffentlichen Straßenverkehr zum Beispiel wägen und halt irgendwie so 30 Kilo, 30 Tonnen Benzin drinnen haben, weil es halt ein Tanklastzug ist. Da wird es sicherlich einigermaßen hohe Anforderungen daran geben, wie halt die Sicherheit dieser Systeme auszusehen hat, damit die A nicht gehyjagt werden können, oder in dem Fall sich ohne erheblichen Aufwand gehyjagt werden können und B halt auch einfach keine groben Fehler machen.
Du meinst etwa so hohe Anforderungen, wie die Amerikaner an die Computer stellen, die sie in ihrer Energieversorgung einsetzen?
Ja, vermutlich wird das so sein.
Ungefähr so hohe Anforderungen.
Ja, ich mein jetzt mal ganz einfach gesagt, es gibt ja auch riesengroße Verlustausfälle durch sowas, wie du schon angesagt, so ein Industrieroboter, der ja eigentlich auch nachts arbeiten kann. Und ich sag mal, nachts muss nicht unbedingt jemand so ein Industrieroboter überwachen oder irgendein Überwachungspersonal, dass vielleicht noch als Minimalanstellung dann in so einer Firma da ist, kriegt das nicht mit und lasst mal so einen Hacker dort irgendwo eindringen. Oder manche mögen es auch Cracker nennen, können wir uns jetzt darüber streiten. Das sind ja riesige Verlustausfälle, wenn da jetzt zum Beispiel ein Band einfach mal nur still steht. Ich meine, das ist ja jetzt der geringste Fall. Abgesehen von technischen Schwierigkeiten, dass ein Roboter mal was kaputtmacht, was er ja nun eigentlich gar nicht soll. Sondern er soll ja irgendwo vielleicht was zusammenschrauben. Oder vorhin war auch schön im IRC angesprochen, wenn die Software zum Beispiel von Microsoft ist, dann wären die Roboter ständig krank, weil sie ein unverreichendes Immunsystem haben. Also fand ich auch ziemlich interessant, weil das sind ja auch Punkte, die man in Betracht ziehen muss. Und wie schon gesagt, heute Tage und auch in geraumer Zukunft wird so ein Roboter nur aus Computerteilen bestehen, die ja auch nur von den Menschen programmiert sind. Und doch der macht irgendwo Fehler.
Also möglicherweise verhindert sogar die Tendenz, dass die Produktqualität insgesamt deutlich schlechter wird, überhaupt das Aufkommen funktionierender Roboter. Weil so nach nach meinem Gefühl wird zwar wird zwar im Moment vieles auch billiger, aber ich habe selten ist mir so viel Technik zu Hause abgeraucht oder kaputt gegangen wie in den letzten fünf Jahren.
Und das ist aber keine Technik, die gesetzlich reguliert ist. Also zum Beispiel an die Anforderungen denkst, die halt so ein Autopilot erfüllen muss, bevor sie den fliegen lassen oder an die Anforderungen, die halt erfüllt werden müssen, bevor halt sagen wir mal dann zum Beispiel so ein LKW automatisch auf die Straße gelassen wird. Ich denke, das sind so Sachen, wo der Gesetzegeber dann gerne noch mal die sicherheitstechnischen Aspekte ins Feld führt, um halt irgendwie den Arbeitsplätzeverlust noch mal ein paar Jahre nach hinten hinauszuschieben.
Ich glaube, dass der Gesetzgeber da eher viel, viel später kommt. Es wird dann letztendlich alles über Produkthaftung vermute ich abgewickelt und da wird genau die Sorgfalt...
Nicht in Deutschland.
Da wird man genau die Sorgfalt walten lassen. Also nimm an, es gibt ja eine ganze Reihe von PKWs mit Einparkautomatiken und da ist nichts gesetzlich geregelt bei denen. Also da gibt es eine Einparkautomatik, da gibt es keine speziellen Prüf- oder Zulassungsvorschriften soweit.
Und so bei den Spurassistenten?
Da gibt es die ganz normale Straßenverkehrszulassungsordnung und klar, die testen das alle und die sind ja auch diese Spurassistenten, kannst du ja jederzeit mit einer Lenkbewegung auch, also die lenken ja nicht wirklich, sondern die geben dann nur ein bisschen Kraft auf dein Lenkrad. Und insofern, also da schreckt man sich, schreckt man doch noch ein Stück vor zurück.
Also mir hat mal jemand von einem größeren Autohersteller gesagt, also Autos selber fahren lassen könnten wir schon innerhalb von wenigen Jahren, wenn wir jetzt Geld drauf tun wollen. Es gibt halt nur einen großen Grund, warum es nicht passiert, nämlich dass die Leute halt noch gerne selber Auto fahren. Und er rechnet halt damit, dass es im Fernfahrerbereich als erstes passieren wird, dass es da Assistenten gibt, die dann irgendwann so intelligent sind, dass sie eigentlich selber noch GPS Koordinaten fahren können. Und zum anderen natürlich, wer heute so eine S-Klasse kauft, der ist halt in der Regel älter als 60 und das sind halt irgendwie 15 Jahre später. Die Leute werden halt heute auch immer älter, einfach schlicht objektiv nicht in der Lage sein Auto zu fahren. Und der will aber trotzdem noch gerne selbst Automobil sein, und sich einen Chauffeur anzustellen. Das sind die beiden Felder, wo sie sehen, dass dann als erstes ein Markt für autonomes Fahren entstehen könnte.
Sind sie nicht mehr fähig Auto zu fahren wollen, aber ja super. Ich hab in Paris mal gesehen, in Paris gibt es eine vollautomatische U-Bahn mittlerweile. Die Linie 1. Wirklich?
So richtig schick?
So richtig schick, ohne Fahrer vorne und alles. In Paris sah es einfach besser aus. Und zwar hatte die nämlich so tolle Glaswände. Also es war so gemacht, dass quasi der gesamte Bahnsteig war verglast. Und du konntest dann, diese Bahn hat wirklich auf einen Zentimeter genau sich eingepasst, hat angehalten und dann sind quasi vor den Türen der Bahn noch mal Glastüren aufgeglitten.
Das ist aber die Loser-Lösung.
Ja, das mit den Glastüren, das hat einen anderen Zweck, dass das in London auch eingeführt worden, weil einfach zu häufig der U-Bahn-Verkehr durch Selbstmörder zum Erliegen gebracht wurde. Und die sind wirklich in erster Linie dazu da, um Leute davon abzuhalten, sich umzubringen.
Also die U-Bahn in Berlin war, ich glaube, so eine kurze Strecke am Kudamm, irgendwo waren 4-5 Stationen und ich glaube, die fährt sogar immer noch. Das ist eine normale U-Bahn, da ist nichts anders. Da sitzt halt noch keiner drin. Wusste ich gar nicht. Die ist halt fernüberwacht, hat da reichlich viel. Mir fällt der Name nicht ein.
Ist das diese zwei Stationen vom neuen U-Bahnplatz, die U5 oder was?
U5 ist glaube ich geil.
Nee, U5 ist ja ganz woanders.
Okay, ich hab's gerade nicht im Kopf.
Irgendjemand wird's wohl wissen.
Jedenfalls, natürlich passiert das schon. Ich glaube aber, Deutschland wird eines der Länder sein, wo es extrem sichere Robotergesetze geben wird. Da bin ich fest schon überzeugt, weil man kann damit die Entwicklung natürlich noch ein bisschen aufhalten.
Ich sehe das nicht so. Also gerade wenn du dir anguckst, die Störungen in der Kfz Elektronik, auch bei den deutschen Luxusfahrzeugherstellern, deuten eher in eine andere Richtung.
Ja, das ist richtig. Und wenn man den Faden jetzt mal ganz blöd einfach mal weiter spinnt. Angenommen in, ich weiß nicht wie vielen Jahren, lass mal die ganzen Roboter selber denken. Angenommen künstliche Intelligenz, es funktioniert mal anständig, dann kann man das doch immer noch in, ich sag mal, unser System, in das Menschensystem einpassen. Der Roboter denkt zwar dann selbst, kann aber eigentlich immer noch manipuliert werden von anderen Robotern, so wie du heutzutage einen anderen Menschen geschickt manipulieren kannst durch verschiedene, ich sag mal, Mechanismen jetzt. Kannst du das dann können, dass Roboter untereinander denke ich mal sicherlich auch. Also dieser Sicherheitsaspekt wird irgendwie nie wegzukriegen sein, egal wie sich der Mensch oder hinterher dann der Roboter selber anstellt. Also das sind so Dinge, wo man auch bei der Entwicklung hat schon darüber nachdenken muss.
Mein Asimov hat sich da ja mit seinen drei Robotergesetzen auch sehr früh Gedanken darüber gemacht, aber ich fürchte, dass diese drei Robotergesetze so niemals Realität werden, weil sie sind ein Begriff, die Robotergesetze. Im Prinzip ja, das erste ist, dass kein Roboter einem Menschen Schaden zufügen kann und darf. Und das zweite ist, dass kein Roboter durch Untätigkeit zulassen darf, dass einem Menschen Schaden zugefügt wird, es sei denn, es verstößt gegen das erste Gesetz.
Es war noch Teil des ersten Gesetzes. Also Untätigkeit war noch Teil des ersten Gesetzes. Das zweite ist, dass er den Befehl des Menschen gehorchen muss, es führt einem dazu, dass ein anderer Mensch zu Schaden kommt. Und das dritte Gesetz ist, dass er sie selbst erhält.
Genau, stimmt, das ist ja Selbsterhaltung. Und gerade genau diese drei Gesetze werden in dem Bereich, wo am meisten Geld reinfließt im Moment, nämlich in die militärische Verwendung von Robotern, da sind natürlich genau diese drei Gesetze überhaupt nicht brauchbar.
Präzise, also da die Forschung findet momentan genau in den Bereichen statt, wo halt die Asimov-Gesetze einfach nur im Wege stehen.
Man sieht ja auch schon, selbst wenn der Film iRobot in manchen Dingen ziemlich flach ist, auch dort wurden die drei Gesetze ja angewandt und man sieht es ist auch ausnutzbar. Also es ist nicht alles perfekt in der Richtung.
Ja gut, also da gibt es ja diese schönen Geschichten von Asimov, aber was diese Militärgeschichten betrifft, da geht es eigentlich nur um den zweiten Aspekt, nämlich irgendwie der Roboter soll den Befehlen des Menschen gehorchen, dem er gehorchen soll und zwar auch genau niemand anderem. Und da passiert gerade auch wirklich richtig viel.
Wie war heute die Meldung für ein Spiel?
127 Milliarden Dollar wollen sie irgendwie in Entwicklung autonomer militärischer Systeme pumpen.
Die Amerikaner.
Die Amerikaner, genau. Und wenn man sich so anguckt, was heute schon passiert, also die Drohnen, sprich unnormale Flugzeuge, werden systematisch eingesetzt, jetzt gerade im Iran. Jetzt werden demnächst halt auch unbemannte Landsysteme, die bewaffnet sind, eingeführt, das heißt also so eine kleine Kiste, die halt zwar noch ferngesteuert wird und nur automatisch Hindernissen ausweichen kann, aber halt schon irgendwie mit einer großen Kanone bewaffnet ist, um mal um die Ecke zu gucken, ob da irgendjemand hockt. Diese Sachen, die werden jetzt beschleunigt eingeführt, einfach deswegen, weil die Amerikaner natürlich ihre Verluste reduzieren wollen. Also die wollen halt möglichst wenig Leute verlieren, weil wenn so ein Roboter dabei draufgeht, irgendwo ist es total egal, es halt materialweise eingeschrieben wird.
Ist eigentlich toll. Ist doch auch toll. Ich meine, dann geht kein Mensch mehr dabei verloren, aber kriegen sich da Roboter, irgendwann ist klar, die Roboter haben gewonnen, alles klar, danke.
Im Moment haben die anderen nur keine Roboter, die haben halt, im Augenblick sind die Roboter dafür gebohrt, Menschen umzubringen.
Die haben noch weiche Ziele, wie das so schön heißt.
Naja und demnächst wird es halt so sein, dass die Kriege sowieso alle virtuell ausgeführt werden, beziehungsweise Roboter gegen Roboter kämpfen und die Menschen dann irgendwo, wenn es überhaupt noch Menschen sind, irgendwo im Hintergrund sitzen und die Teile nur noch steuern, beziehungsweise die Befehle geben, das ist ja eigentlich egal.
Naja das Problem ist, dass der größte Teil der Menschheit kann, sich nicht leisten, Roboter zu bauen. Da muss man halt auch mal dran denken.
Bis wir wirklich Roboter gegen Roboter haben, vergeht noch etwas Zeit.
Erst mal kommt überhaupt erst mal US-amerikanische Roboter gegen Selbstmordattentäter.
Naja ich glaube so 2050 der große Krieg gegen China wird es dann werden, wir dann das erste mal Roboter gegen Roboter antreten.
Er hat da mal einen schönen Satz gemacht, der sagte, ich weiß so nicht mit welchen Waffen sich die Menschen im dritten Weltkrieg bekämpfen werden, aber im vierten werden es auf jeden Fall Keulen sein. Er könnte Recht haben.
David, dank dir für den Anruf.
Felicitas aus Berlin zum Telefon.
Hi.
Abend.
Ja, also ich wollte zum Aspekt nochmal was sagen, dass man Angst haben müsste, dass irgendwann die Roboter so intelligent sein werden, dass sie die Menschheit unterjochen werden. Also ich denke gerade dadurch, dass es in Science Fiction so wirklich ausführlich beschrieben wird, werden sich die Menschen dafür hüten, jeweils jemals die Roboter so stark zu entwickeln, dass sie den Menschen übermächtig sind.
In Science Fiction wurde auch der Überwachungsstaat irgendwie äußerst ausführlich beschrieben und wirklich in allen Details und trotzdem haben wir ihn heute.
Ja, aber ich meine, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel an Matrix denke, bei Überwachungsstaat geht es ja nicht um die Bedrohung der Menschheit, sondern um die Überwachung der Menschheit vielleicht. Aber ich meine, es geht ja nicht um das Leben und um die Ethik der Menschen. Und ich meine, mal als Gegenbeispiel zum Beispiel, also als ein ähnliches Beispiel zu sagen, vor 30 Jahren wurde eine Wirtschaftsprognose gegeben, dass im Jahre 1995 die Wirtschaft dann hier erliegen wird, weil sämtliche Ressourcen und die Entwicklung aufgebraucht sein werden. Und es ist gerade nicht eingetreten, weil eben die Menschen nach dieser Prognose vorgehütet haben, diese Entwicklung weiterzugehen.
Also du unterstellst, dass die Menschheit in der Lage ist, bewusst zu handeln?
Ja, so ungefähr. Und außerdem denke ich auch, dass zwar die Entwicklung schnell voranschreiten wird, allerdings ich glaube nicht, dass wir in den nächsten 50 Jahren so weit kommen werden, dass die Roboter wirklich die Arbeit übernehmen. Ich denke zwar schon, dass die Entwicklung schnell voranschreitet, aber wenn man sieht, dass so in Richtung Künstliche Intelligenz in den letzten Jahren so passiert ist, ich bin jetzt zwar nicht ganz firm da in dem Bereich, aber ich denke, dass es nicht so schnell vorangeht, wie viele denken, dass es in den nächsten 10, 20 Jahren schon passieren wird.
Das ist eine Sache, die die Informatiker immer wieder sagen, so dass der, das sagen wir mal, wenn man sich die Künstliche Intelligenz halt im Detail anguckt, dass es dann doch irgendwie schon einigermaßen enttäuschend ist. Was ich aber faszinierend finde, ist, seit es diesen Paradigmenwechsel hingab, dass man sagt, künstliche Intelligenz braucht einen Körper. Das heißt also, künstliche Intelligenz kann nicht irgendwie ein wissensbasiertes System sein, was in irgendeinem Computer existiert, sondern sie braucht tatsächlich einen Körper, sie braucht Interaktion mit der Umgebung, sie braucht Sensorik. Seitdem ist da eine ganze Menge passiert, also seitdem gab es eine ganze Menge Fortschritt, den man auch, sag ich mal, anfassen kann und insofern weiß ich nicht genau, ob diese Optimismus zu sagen, die Forschung ist da so hinreichend hinterher oder ist ein hinreichend komplexes Problem, dass es nicht zum gesellschaftlichen Problem gehen kann, ob der wirklich so haltbar ist.
Ja, also ich denke schon, dass es vielleicht irgendwann passieren könnte, dass es irgendwann zum Problem wird. Aber ich denke, dass ich dann nicht mehr auf dieser Erde weilen werde. Also ich denke nicht, dass es so schnell vorangeht, dass wir...
Dass du da noch darunter leiden müsstest.
Da würde ich dir auch recht geben. Also ich bin da auch eher der Skeptiker. Ich glaube, dass in den nächsten 50 Jahren bei der künstlichen Intelligenz nicht viel mehr passieren wird als in den letzten 50 Jahren.
Und die Frage ist doch, ob tatsächlich sowas wie künstliche Intelligenz im Sinne von irgendwie nahezu Bewusstsein überhaupt erforderlich ist, um diese Viecher tatsächlich zum Problem werden zu lassen.
Naja, die Frage, ab wann sind diese Viecher ein Problem?
Also in dem Moment, wo sie sich gegen dich wenden. Ich meine, wenn du dir mal heute die heute verbreiteten Roboter, nämlich die Windows Computer, anschaust, dann ist es irgendwie de facto so, dass 80 Prozent derer, die irgendwie am Internet sind, bereits von irgendwelchen fremden Mächten gefasst wurden und Daten verschicken, die du nie verschicken wolltest. Und das Problem hat man natürlich mit jeder Technik.
Also das ist, da kann man auch sagen, das Problem hatte man auch mit Autos vor 70 Jahren und hat man auch jetzt noch mit Autos. Und mit allem, was mit irgendwie mit Technik zu tun hat, mit Elektrizität hat man genau das selbe Problem, dass es da irgendwann, wenn man da nicht genug aufpasst, sich ein gegen, dass ich das gegen anwenden kann.
Ja gut, aber Autos vor 80 Jahren waren ja keine autonomen Systeme. Also die haben ja nun wirklich gar nichts getan, wenn ich sich wirklich aktiv darum geguckt.
Ein Computer heute ist auch kein autonomes System.
Ach wieso, die hat aufgehört.
Der ist einfach nicht fremd.
Nur das, was ich ihm sage und wenn ich ihm was falsches sage, dann...
Nee, nee, der tut auch das, was jemand anders ihm sagt.
Also, dass irgendjemand ihm sagt, aber es ist noch keine selbstständig denkende Intelligenz.
Nö, das muss es ja auch gar nicht sein. Ich meine, das reicht ja, wenn die andere, wenn derjenige, der ihm das sagt, eine selbstständig denkende Intelligenz ist.
Aber nehmen wir mal, nehmen wir mal bei Beispiel Computer, weil ich ja auch immer oft mit Leuten zu tun habe, die zu mir diesen Satz sagen, diesen magischen Max, hör mal, du kennst dich doch mit Computern aus. Das ist einer der ganz Gefährlichen. Und es ist einfach so, wenn wir mal Intelligenz nehmen, als vielleicht auch die Tatsache, dass man selber das System, was da gerade funktioniert, nicht mehr so genau verstehen kann, dann sind Computer da schon ziemlich weit vorne, weil die machen ziemlich viel. Die fahren irgendwie hoch, da kommt da irgendwie so eine Anmeldemasker, muss man vielleicht sein Passwort eingeben. Die meisten, die haben sowieso gar kein Passwort, dann gehen da ungefähr unten in der Task-Leiste beim durchschnittlichen normalen Noob-Computer irgendwie 10 bis 12 Icons an, von denen sowieso keiner weiß, was das eigentlich ist. Es war da irgendwie alles drauf. Und dann gibt es vielleicht einen Schlauen, der macht mal den Task-Manager auf und stellt fest, dass da von denen, die man sehen kann, irgendwie 30 Prozesse laufen. Und dann würde ich gerne mal wissen, wer irgendwie weiß, was das ist, worum es sich da handelt. Und das ist schon eine Art von Autonomie, würde ich sagen.
Aus diesem Grund haben wir die Gerichte auch beschlossen, dass du für deinen PC nicht mehr verantwortlich bist.
Ja, aber ich denke, dafür gibt es ja die Programmierer. Und es gibt eben immer noch qualifizierte Kräfte, die wissen, was der Computer da macht.
Wenige, sehr wenige nur noch. Da muss ich dir die Illusion leider nehmen.
Also ich guck grad mal, wie viele von den Prozessen, die auf meinem Computer hier gerade laufen, ich etwa eine Ahnung habe, was sie tun.
Also ich glaube, der Punkt ist, Roboter müssen nicht intelligent sein, um ein Problem darzustellen.
Wir haben ja vorhin das militärische Beispiel. Ja, haben wir einen Typen, meinetwegen der hat eine humanoide Form, muss ja nicht mal sein. Nehmen wir an, das ist ein Kasten mit Kanone. Was muss der können? Der muss den Feind erkennen können, der muss den Feind töten können. Das sind die zwei Sachen. Was bringt man dem bei? Man füttert den in Information.
Ja, aber wie kann der Kasten unterscheiden, ob was der Feind ist und was der Freund ist?
Na, mit dem Gesichtserkennungssystem, was auch zum Beispiel in der Stadt London eingesetzt wird, das ziemlich gut funktioniert. Da sehen die schon irgendwie, hu, was für eine Datenbank ist das, wem haben die alles fotografiert, vielleicht machen die das immer in ein Satellitensystem, die scannen einmal die Area, dann haben die 15.000 Gesichter, dann sagen die, die sind schon mal in der Datenbank. Und wahrscheinlich ist es weniger Kollateralschaden als ein Mensch, der irgendwie nervös durch die Gegend rennt und irgendwie total Angst hat irgendwo im Irak und dann irgendjemand erschießt am besten noch seinen eigenen Kumpel oder so. Also das ist, wenn so eine Maschine dich töten will, dann geht das relativ schnell. Da muss auch nicht viel passieren. Da bist du einfach das bewegliche Ziel fertig.
Naja, aber es gibt ja immer einen Menschen dahinter, der diese Programmierung vornimmt oder der aber seine Macht wird größer.
Also was diese Technologie tut, sie ist ja sie verstärkt Macht. Also nehmen wir nur mal an, die Amerikaner werden laut Plan fertig. 2008 wollen sie in der Lage sein, 2008 acht vollautomatische Jagdflugzeuge mit irgendwie Bombenbestückung in Shipping Container zu verpacken, die in jedem beliebigen Ort der Welt auszupacken. Auf die Landebahn zu stellen und von zwei Leuten kontrolliert die Ziel angeben zu lassen. Da gibt man nur noch eine Zielkoordinator ein, legt ihr alles angrifffest und dann war das die Geschichte. Und stell dir mal vor, irgendwie so drei so eine Container werden geklaut. So jemand mobs ihnen diese drei Dinge am Hafen weg und mit der zugehörigen Munition kriegt das System aufgemacht und ist plötzlich in der Lage zu zweit eine komplette Jagdflugzeugstaffel zu kontrollieren. Das ist eine Sache, die hat es vorher in der Geschichte nicht gegeben. Also das trat einfach nicht auf. Und das ist genau die Art von Problemen, mit der wir das zu tun haben werden, dass nämlich Technologie, in der Macht konzentriert wird, tatsächlich zugänglich wird für relativ wenige Leute. Also das ist sozusagen natürlich unterhalb von dem, sagen wir mal zwei Leute haben eine Atombombe, aber das tatsächlich real anwendbarer macht. Atombombe kann man in der Regel nicht viel anfangen mit Jagdflugzeug schon.
Atombombe ist vielleicht etwas zu extrem, aber es reicht ja schon irgendeine biologische Waffe oder eine chemische Waffe. Also ich hab mal eine Geschichte gehört, da hat ein 16-jähriger Junge Senfgas hergestellt oder Napalm in seinem Hauslabor, in seinem Chemie-Baukasten.
Das Register hat ja, theregister.com, ne COUK ist ja so eine etwas zynische englische Webseite, die die IT-Industrie begleitet und die hat seit neuerer um eine Rubrik Rhythm Machines Strike Back, wo sie halt diese ganzen Inzidenz werden, halt Maschinen halt anfangen komische Dinge zu tun, halt reporten und natürlich mit so einem gewissen Blick darauf nach dem Motto halt, naja, die Maschinen fangen langsam an ihren Aufstand vorzubereiten, also angefangen von Autos, bei denen ein Tempomat durchdreht oder Toastern, die selbstständig explodieren und so weiter und so fort. Und wenn man diese so unter diesem Aspekt so ein bisschen liest, dann kann man sich das schon so vorstellen, dass diese Roboter irgendwann halt auch mal zu so einem echten Problem werden. Also dass man halt wirklich dann irgendwann Roboter klatschen geht, weil das halt nervt.
Von meinem Toast habe ich auch Respekt.
2015.
Ja, guten Tag, ich bin der Bernd von den Bibuletten und Deutschland oder die Welt im Jahre 2015 sieht so aus, ich bin extrem großer Optimist und sage, es herrscht Weltfrieden.
2015. Ein Blick in die Zukunft und im Radio.
Fritz.
Wieso lachen hier schon wieder. Hier hat das Chaos Radio auf Fritz mit Tim, Pavel, Frank und Max, meiner Person, Thema heute Abend Robotik und wir sind so ein bisschen beim militärischen Punkt stehen geblieben. Ich bin auch noch da. Ich hab doch Tim gesagt am Anfang als ersten Namen.
Echt als ersten?
Ja, als ersten hab ich gesagt Tim.
Ich glaub nicht an Weltfrieden 2015.
Wieso denn nicht?
Ich hol mir das jetzt so ein bisschen, dass du von der Seite reinkommst.
Das ist einfach nur traurig, weil ich deinen Namen gesagt hab.
Das hat's noch nie gegeben.
Also das wär ja auch mal was Neues. Also nicht, dass es in irgendeiner Form erstrebenswert wäre, aber die Tendenz geht natürlich in eine ganz andere Richtung. Das zeigt ja gerade diese Meldung.
Aber vielleicht, wenn wir Radiosender haben, wo wir das völlig ausblenden können, dass es Kriege gibt, dann erfahren wir wenigstens nicht davon.
Mir würde es ja schon mal reichen, wenn es Radiosender gibt, wo man mal die Sportnachrichten ausbreiten kann. Das wär bestimmt ein Beitrag zum Weltfrieden, ich bin sicher.
So, der Dominik aus Berlin-Kreuzberg ist am Telefon. Nein, Dominik, Tachchen bist du noch dran? Ist er nicht, wir reden uns aber von Rolf.
Das sind die fiesen Telefonroboter disconnected worden.
Ja, vielleicht sind alle rausgeflogen. Das könnte natürlich nicht das eigentlich probieren.
Frank, noch mal eine kurze Frage, was hier gerade beim Chat noch mal reinkommt. Diese Gerichtsentscheidung, dass man nicht mehr für seinen Rechner vollständig ist. Hast du da eine Quelle am Start?
Na ja, gibt einige Urteile meistens halt in Fällen von Besitz von sagen wir mal strafrechtlich relevanten Daten, wo Leute sich damit zu Recht oder zu Unrecht verteidigt haben, dass sie gesagt haben, dieser PC ist so komplex, den habe ich nicht mehr unter meiner Kontrolle. Und dieses Internet und dieses Windows ist ohnehin so anfällig und so voll mit Spalware, Trojanern, Backdoors, Viren und so weiter und so fort, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass der durchschnittliche PC User noch in der Lage ist, festzustellen, ob jemand anders seinen Computer unter Kontrolle hat, eigentlich null ist. Das heißt also der PC stellt eine so dermaßen komplexe Maschine da, dass dem durchschnittlichen Anwender nicht zuzumuten ist, diese Technologie vollständig zu beherrschen. Und da gab es mehrere Landgerichtsentscheidungen, soweit ich mich erinnere, die genau dieses gesagt haben. Also gesagt haben, wenn halt irgendwie per Computerforensik festgestellt werden kann, dass dieser PC entsprechend mit einer Hintertür versehen war, da ein Trojaner darauf installiert war, über den andere Leute übers Netz zugreifen konnten. Und anzunehmen ist, dass der Benutzer halt aus seiner sonstigen Lebensführung und so weiter und so fort nicht derjenige ist, der diesen z.B. einen Hackerangriff, der über einen PC gestartet wurde, durchgeführt haben kann. Dann ist er im Zweifel halt freizusprechen, weil er kann einfach diesen PC nicht mehr unter seiner Kontrolle haben. Und wenn man sich halt anguckt, typischerweise, wenn halt irgendwie Angriffe gegen Webseiten und so weiter und so fort passieren, sowohl bei diesen Dinner-of-Service-Attacken, da sind halt zehntausende PCs, die werden halt ferngesteuert. Und verursachen halt...
Interessanterweise nennt man das dann Botnetz.
Genau, das sind dann solche Botnetze, als Kurs von Robot. Und das ist tatsächlich das, was da draußen im Internet jeden Tag passiert. Also das ist jetzt nicht irgendeine Zukunft, sondern das ist das, was wirklich jeden Tag da abläuft, schon seit Jahren eigentlich. Und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das mit Robotern eh nicht anders sein wird, weil letzten Endes, so ein Roboter wird ein Netz haben, der wird sich seine Software-Updates über UMTS sorgen. In Zweifel wird die Firma, die diesen Roboter an den User vermietet oder verkauft hat, in der Lage sein, auf diesen Roboter zuzugreifen, um halt irgendwie Verhaltskorrekturen einzuspielen oder ein neues Software-Modul, dass er irgendwie plötzlich auch noch irgendwie Windeln waschen kann, einzuspielen und so weiter und so fort. Und da wird es halt sicher auch ohne Ende geben. Und die Frage ist natürlich, wie geht man dann halt einfach rechtlich damit um?
Und dann stehen Sie da die gleißenden neuen Maschinen, alle im Park, Hunderte und sammeln den Hunde-Code ein. Und auf einmal drehen Sie alle den Kopf nach links und fangen an in eine ganz andere Richtung zu marschieren.
Oder mit Hunde-Code nach dir zu schmeißen.
Also ich meine, irgendwie Handys und Windows-Rechner sind auf jeden Fall schon mal unter externer Kontrolle. Und solche autonomen Systeme sind dann nochmal eine wunderschöne Vision. Oh Gott, wir machen ja jetzt hier eine Angst. Aber vielleicht gibt es ja auch noch mehr positive Aspekte. Ich meine, es gibt ja auch eine...
Das reißt du jetzt nochmal rum. Ist klar.
Es gibt ja auch eine Menge Spaß. Es gibt ja auch eine Menge Spaß.
Ist ja schon nach Mitternacht.
Warte, warte, eine Sekunde, eine Sekunde.
Was denn?
Was spricht? Das ist übrigens der Timphofall, weil es seinen Namen nicht deutlich genug sein sollte.
Ja, was ja sehr auffällig ist, dass diese ganze Robotergeschichte wurde vor allem von Leuten aufgenommen, die das Ganze sehr sportlich gesehen haben. Fußball scheint das globale Thema zu sein. Es gibt da auch so eine Veranstaltung, die regelmäßig durchgeführt wird der RoboCup, wo in unterschiedlichen Disziplinen Fußballspiele ausgefochten werden. Ich habe da selber leider noch nicht teilgenommen. Sicherlich ganz interessant. Wechselnde Orte. Es gibt da verschiedene Ligen für unterschiedliche Arten von Robotern. Kleine große Aibo, Aibo, die aufeinander zulaufen. Also dieser schon erwähnte Sony Computerhund, aber eben auch einfach nur so kleine Puckartige Roboter, die natürlich einen sehr großen Bewegungsradius haben. Da geht es auch schon deutlich schneller zur Sache. Und das erklärte Ziel der Szene ist halt bis, was sagen sie immer, 2050 wollen sie halt im Prinzip Roboter am Start haben, die eine menschliche Fußballmannschaft schlagen.
Nein, nein, die Fußballweltmeisterschaft gewinnen können.
Das erklärte Ziel ist 2050 die Fußballweltmeisterschaft gewinnen können.
Genau, also sozusagen alle schlagen.
Mit Satellitenunterstützung also mit...
Naja, höchstens mit Schiedsrichterunterstützung.
Also ich denke, sie müssen halt schon genauso autonom funktionieren. Also Trainerzuruf und sowas schon, aber nicht jetzt WLAN oder so.
Also ich glaube, das wird schneller gehen als 2050.
Niemals, ich glaub schon.
Was sagt so der Mann, der gerne die Sportmeldungen ausblendet?
Genau, ich meine, was mich an Sport, also ob er aufs Ziel war, Sport zu kommen, was mich an Sport anödet, ist diese Überregulierung. Also ich meine, da findet kein technologischer Wettstreit statt. Sogar die Formel 1 ist mittlerweile reglementiert. Anstatt da mal hinzugehen und zu sagen, okay, feel free, dobt euch wie ihr wollt, schmeißt rein was ihr wollt, habt wenigstens ein Logo von eurem Pharmakonzern auf dem T-Shirt, baut die stärksten Motoren an, die ihr bauen könnt, baut euch da autonome Fahrsysteme ein, aber redet wenigstens darüber, damit die Ingeniers auch noch ein bisschen Spaß daran haben können. Aber nee, der wird überreglementiert, wird so getan, als würde es niemand tun. Natürlich tut es jeder, jeder dobt, jeder baut die stärksten Motoren an, die er einbauen kann. Und alle tun so, als wäre alles Friede vor der Erdkuchen. Bei so einer Roboter-Fußballweltmeisterschaft wäre dann endlich mal wieder so eine technologische Challenge dabei. Das wäre dann interessant für Leute wie mich, die einfach mal viel mehr Interesse daran haben, was steckt da für Technologie hinter, irgendwie, was haben sie da an Software getan und so weiter und so fort. Das sind die Sachen, die bei der Formel 1 ausgeblendet werden. Da steht dann irgendwie dieser Michael Schumerer da vorne und die 500 Software-Engineers, die da sein Fahrzeug fahren getunet haben, von denen redet niemand.
Du brauchst eine Formel 0, nicht? So ohne Fahrer.
Einfach nur so Geschosse, die mit 900 Stundenkilometern in die Straße ziehen, dass man es nur noch um eine Zeitgruppe sehen kann.
Genau, das wird natürlich erst passieren, wenn es vollautomatische Fahrsysteme gibt, dann wird es natürlich auch eine Rallye für vollautomatische Autosysteme.
Ja, aber die gibt es doch jetzt schon.
Die können doch im Prinzip die Fahrzeuge sogar komplett, ich meine, sie zeichnen ja jetzt schon die volle, Sie könnten sie bauen, das wäre kein Problem. die volle Sensorik auf, sie können die kompletten, also die ganzen Rennen nachfahren. Die haben die komplette Sensorik aufgezeichnet, die ganze Telemetrie ist aufgezeichnet, sie können im Prinzip das Auto da wieder hinstellen und brauchen nur die gleichen Pedale zu benutzen. Das ist ja eh alles digitale Eingabe. Und dann fährt das Ding irgendwie los.
Und ich meine, also wie gesagt, das wäre glaube ich mal so eine Sache, die mich wieder reizen würde. Was uns jetzt aber eigentlich interessiert ist, Fußball. Wie würdet ihr das irgendwie bedenklich finden, wenn so ein roboter Team, sagen wir mal 2015, um in eurem tollen Radiorahmen zu bleiben, die Fußballer Weltmeisterschaft gewinnen würde, würdet ihr das unfair finden oder wäre das irgendwie, ja, weiß ich nicht, ethisch, moralisch verwerflich?
Fault man die dann mehr als die anderen?
Vor allen Dingen, was ist, wenn die dann faken? Das war doch eine Schwalbe, das hat doch jeder gesehen.
Er ist ja ferngesteuert.
Ja, das wäre interessant. Vor allen Dingen ist das endlich mal die Schachfrage projiziert auf die ganzen Sportler. Die Schach ist ja genau das seit Jahren am Start.
Ja, und bei Schach ist es ja eigentlich auch schnell entschieden worden. Die haben sich immer gefragt, irgendwie kann ein Computer einen Menschen schlagen im Schach? Und ja, während sie noch...
Hat nur 50 Jahre gedauert.
Genau, hat nur 50 Jahre gedauert und dann war Schluss. So, und jetzt ist es irgendwie gar nicht mehr die Frage, ob er irgendwie geschlagen werden kann. Jetzt die Frage, kann ein Mensch überhaupt einen... Kann er überhaupt noch gewinnen?
Das ist jetzt die Frage. Nein, die Frage bei den Schachtturnieren ist, wie viel Computerhilfe dürfen diese Meisterschachspieler, also die menschlichen Schachspieler tatsächlich in Anspruch nehmen?
Die sind ja mittlerweile auch schon komplett digital genug.
Aber Schacht ist auch vergleichsweise trivial mit einem Fußballspiel, ja.
Ach, es sind schon die Guck. Also ich meine, Fußball 11 Leute und ein Ball, bitte dich.
Okay, Jungs, bevor wir jetzt hier in Krieg kommen, ich erhol dich mal den Dominik. Dominik, bist du jetzt dran?
Ich bin jetzt dran.
Super, hallo.
Ja, ich wollte noch mal was zu der künstlichen Intelligenz sagen, was da vorhin aufgekommen ist und was auch über den Irrkrieg geht oder ging mittlerweile auch schon eine Weile her. Und einfach, glaubt ihr denn wirklich, dass das prinzipiell...
Wer raschelt denn da?...
prinzipiell möglich ist, intelligente Roboter zu bauen. Also Stichwort Touring-Test. Weil daran hängen ja auch ziemlich viele von diesen moralischen Problemen, oder? Also nur wenn man ein anderes Wesen sozusagen als Teil der moralischen Sprachgemeinschaft irgendwie akzeptiert, dann hat das überhaupt Sinn von Ethik und Moral zu reden.
Tja, also sagen wir mal so, ein Altenpflegeroboter, der halt sich mit dir irgendwie einigermaßen sinnvoll unterhalten kann, der muss eigentlich schon verdammt nah dran sein an so einem Touring-Test. Also möglicherweise muss er den Touring-Test nicht wirklich bestehen können, aber er muss schon ziemlich nah dran sein. Und meine Vermutung ist ja, dass wenn er halt, sagen wir mal so was wie Google eingebaut hat, dass er tatsächlich dazu in der Lage sein könnte, ziemlich lange durchzuhalten.
Also der Touring-Test ist natürlich kein gutes Beispiel, um einen Roboter jetzt wirklich zu testen.
Was macht denn der Touring-Test genau?
Also Touring-Test ist ein Test, den der Mathematiker Alan Touring sich überlegt hat, um zu testen, ob eine Maschine intelligent ist, indem man diese Maschine befragt. Also man stellt ihr Fragen und mit dem Ziel herauszufinden, handelt es sich um eine Maschine oder einen Menschen, die am anderen Ende sind. Und ja, normalerweise genügen bei den bei den besten KI-Programmen so drei bis fünf Fragen in etwa geschickt gestellt, um das am anderen Ende halt als ja als Computer zu entlarven.
Was sind das für Fragen? Nur mal so die Kategorien, dass so sehr existenzielle Dinge irgendwie. Magst du die Farbe rot lieber als die Farbe blau oder warum oder irgendwie was? Oder hast du hast du Angst vor der Dunkelheit oder was sind das für Fragen?
Naja, also was man dazu sehen muss. Die Fragen beim Touring-Test werden von Leuten gestellt, die darauf spezialisiert sind, Fragen für den Touring-Test zu stellen. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es Leute, die sich in Chats stundenlang mit Bots unterhalten, also mit Liza Arting, Liza war so eines der ersten Systeme dieser Art, und denen entweder nichts ausmacht, dass da auf der anderen Seite ein Skript oder ein Programm ist oder die es schlicht nicht merken.
Also die Frage, um nochmal kurz auf deine Frage zu beantworten, die Fragen beim Touring-Test nutzen in der Regel die Schwächen des Sprachverständnisses und Spracherkennens aus. Das heißt, sie stellen teilweise entweder schwer zu Verstehende oder doppeldeutige oder mehrdeutige Fragen und versuchen darüber einfach aufs Glatteis zu führen. Es gibt natürlich die Leute, die wiederum diese Intelligenz-Simulatoren schreiben, versuchen dann eventuell ausweichende Fragen zu stellen oder Nachfragestrategien dagegen zu setzen. Aber das Problem ist eben, dass das Sprachverständnis selbst der besten KI-Systeme noch sehr mangelhaft, sehr rudimentär ist und sie durch gerade mehrdeutige Wörter und Kontexte, wo jedem Mensch klar ist, zum Beispiel wenn ich das Wort Wurzel verwende und vorher irgendwie was von Garten oder Bäumen erzählt habe, dann ist klar in welcher Bedeutung das ist, wenn ich vorher mich über Zahlen oder Mathematik unterhalten habe, wieder in ein ganz anderer Kontext und so wird halt mit mehrdeutigen Wörtern und Kontexten gespielt und dann ist es ziemlich schnell klar, dass das kein Mensch ist am anderen Ende.
Aber ich würde mal bestreiten, dass das für so ein Konsumeprodukt irrelevant ist.
Äh, relevant nicht bestreiten.
Also ich würde mal sagen, für ein Konsumeprodukt ist das wirklich egal. Also wenn die Maschine hinreichend gut ist und sich irgendwie genügend lang über die aktuellen Fernsehserien unterhalten kann, sagen wir mal so, die meisten Chatbesucher, die ich kenne, würden den Turing-Test auch nicht bestehen.
Als Menschen, ja, insofern.
Und ich meine, schon mal...
Also Sat1, Frühstücks, Fernsehen, Moderation.
Also das ist ja auch irgendwie alles...
Die kann man vollständig automatisieren, ja. Das wär wahrscheinlich sogar noch witziger, weil die einen großen Wortschatz hätten, die Maschine.
Moderator 2. In der Ankündigung hieß es ja auch, dass es um philosophische Probleme dort gehen soll.
Ja, war ne Lüge. Nee, ist richtig.
Ich hab's vermutet.
Nee, nee, nee, ist richtig.
Es ist natürlich wichtig zu sagen, dass Intelligenz ist ein sprachliches Merkmal und Sprache ist nun mal was Interpretatives, was bis jetzt in einer gewissen Art und Weise nur Menschen oder in der menschlichen Sprachgemeinschaft, also intersubjektiv geteilt, vorkommt. Und wenn man jetzt moralische Probleme auf Roboter, also Asimovs Gesetze und so weiter, anwenden will, dann müssen die eben Mitglied in dieser Sprachgemeinschaft sein. Und es gibt ja gute Argumente dagegen oder viele Gründe, warum man jetzt annehmen kann, dass zum Beispiel Computer prinzipiell nicht intelligent sein können. Searle's Chinese Room ist eigentlich nicht, dass ich jetzt großer Searle Fan wäre, aber ist natürlich ein gutes Argument, warum das prinzipiell nicht funktionieren kann.
Kannst du kurz erläutern, wer das ist?
Das ist ein analytischer Philosoph, der sich über die starke KI auch Gedanken gemacht hat. Und kennt ihr dieses Beispiel mit dem Chinese Room? Nee, das ist ein Gedankenexperiment. Und die Frage, ob Computer überhaupt intelligent werden können. Und er sagt jetzt, man stelle sich vor, ein Raum, der einen Schlitz hat. In diesem Ding, das ist total abgedunkelt, also das ist total geschlossen, sitzt ein Mensch. Und dieser Mensch hat irgendwie zwei Körbe, einen mit ein paar Zeichen drauf. Also durch diesen Schlitz kommen Zeichen rein. Und er hat einen Korb mit ähnlichen Zeichen, also chinesischen Zeichen. Der Mensch in dem Raum spricht kein Chinesisch. Und er hat zwei Bücher. Einmal sozusagen ein Wörterbuch, eine Lexikografie, wo die ganzen Zeichen verzeichnet sind. Und dann ein Buch mit Regeln. Und in dem Buch steht jetzt genau drin, wenn dieses Zeichen kommt, und er kombiniert das alles miteinander, dann kommt er eben durch eine Verfahrensweise darauf, welches Zeichen er durch diesen Schlitz wieder rauskriegt. Von außen könnte das so aussehen, als ob jetzt dieses Zimmer Chinesisch spricht, weil es immer die richtigen Antworten gibt. Aber man kann nicht behaupten, dass der Mensch, der in diesem Raum ist, Chinesisch gelernt hätte.
Uff, da find ich das mit Schrödingers Katze in dieser Box aber einfach.
Also nochmal zurück.
Das ist ein Gedankenexperiment, das die analytischen Philosophen gerne machen. Was man für solche Gedankenexperimente halten kann, ist wieder eine andere Frage. Aber eigentlich illustriert das recht schön, dass wenn jetzt ein Mensch die Aufgabe des Computers übernimmt und immer nur syntaktische Symbolmanipulationen vornimmt, dass er trotzdem kein Verständnis hat, weil da ihm sozusagen die Intentionalität fehlt. Ein Verständnis, ein Wollen, ein Wille.
Aber die Frage ist, braucht er das? Weil, wenn wir uns heute angucken, was hat am meisten Erfolg auf dem Markt? Das was man Good Enough Software nennt. Also Software, die gerade gut genug ist, dass du dafür bereit bist Geld auszugeben. Und meine Vermutung ist, dass diese Anforderungen an KI schlicht überzogen sind. Dass nämlich eine akademische KI nichts mit dem zu tun hat, was auf dem Markt für Roboter oder intelligenten System Erfolg haben wird. Sondern dass es da wieder mal um Good Enough Software geht. Einfaches Beispiel zum Beispiel. Philips hat von der Weile mal für die Deutsche Bahn ein Sprachdialogsystem entwickelt, mit dem man den Fahrplan abfragen kann. Das war 1999 oder so, dass wir damit gespielt haben. Das System war damals schon verblüffend gut. Da kannst du anrufen, sagen, ich möchte morgen früh nach Hamburg fahren. Und zwar nicht so früh. Und das System hat die Sprache gepasst, hat daraus einen Baum gebaut, hat dir eine sinnvolle Antwort gegeben, hat dich gefragt, irgendwie willst du lieber im EC oder ICE fahren? Wann möchtest du fahren? Möchtest du lieber in 845 oder in 925 Zug haben? Möchtest du noch irgendwann zurückfahren und so weiter und so fort? Das System hat sich mit dir unterhalten. Und das war so ein klassischer Ansatz von Good Enough Software. Das hat die Funktionalität, die es erfüllen sollte, perfekt erfüllt, ohne die Anforderungen von akademischer KI zu erfüllen. Ich glaube, das werden genau die Systeme sein, die am Markt kommen.
Ohne tatsächlich zu verstehen, was du sagst.
Es konnte tatsächlich einfach die Logik, die dahinter steht, hinreichend komplex auswählen.
Ja, wobei, wenn wir jetzt mal wieder auf die Fluss... Wenn man mal wieder, ja, also ich würde dem, also ich sehe keinen prinzipiellen Grund, warum Computer oder Maschinen nicht genauso intelligent sein sollten wie Menschen. Ich könnte natürlich umgekehrt die Frage stellen, ist einer von uns wirklich tatsächlich intelligent oder tut er nur so oder woher wissen wir, dass wir hier mit intelligenten Menschen zusammen. Ja, und gerade dieses, also dieses, dieses Gedankenexperiment, was du geschildert hast, wir haben es gerade auch nochmal, auch nochmal kurz nachgelesen. Ich meine, es ist ein chinesisches Zimmer heißt das Lemma. Und man muss ja erst mal bemerken, dass es sich wirklich um ein Gedankenexperiment handelt.
Das heißt, also ein Stück Software würde diese Aufgabe im Zweifel momentan besser erfüllen als ein normaler Mensch.
Ja, und man muss man muss sehen, dass natürlich man in die Software das gut kann, aber eben kein Chinesisch versteht.
Ja, eben der Mensch aber auch nicht.
Das ist ja genau der Punkt, dass es eben um diese Verstehensfrage geht. Verstehen ist ja eine internationale Eigenschaft des Geistes sozusagen. Also eine Fähigkeit zur Interpretation von Sprache und somit auch zu Weltzugang. Also wir haben ja nur sprachlich vermittelten Zugang zur Welt. Also wir können nicht durch die Dinge unter unsere Sprache treten und deswegen kann ich sagen, dass somit der Ansatz der harten KI, die sagt, wir können Maschinen schaffen, die tatsächlich verstehen, mit diesem Gedankenexperiment widerlegt werden.
Das ist schlicht nicht marktgerecht. Also niemand wird bereit sein, das zu finanzieren.
Davon mal ab, ob es marktgerecht ist oder nicht. Bei dem an dem Gedankenexperiment speziell stört mich, dass es ein Postulat macht, was so ich für fragwürdig halte, nämlich dass es möglich ist, diese Regeln in der Form tatsächlich aufzustellen. Fakt ist, es ist bisher noch niemanden gelungen, ein solches derartiges Regelwerk aufzustellen. Ich meine, das ist ja das Bemühen oder Bestreben, halt einen Touring-Test zu bestehen oder oder auszutricksen. Und es gibt eine solche Software nicht, sodass auch dieser dieser Mensch mit diesem hypothetischen Regelwerk da drin aus meiner Sicht etwas ist, was so nicht existieren kann. Es sei denn, er würde wirklich verstehen, was er da tut. Und jeder, der mal versucht hat, automatische Sprachübersetzung zu auszuprobieren oder gar gar selber zu entwickeln, weiß auch praktisch um die Unmöglichkeit. Also ich behaupte schlichtweg dieses Gedankenexperiment. Also dieses Regelwerk kann es nicht geben, wird es nicht geben. Es sei denn, man hat eine Intelligenz da drin, die mit Kreativität, Fassines Erfahrung und einem tatsächlich einem Bild, einem Modell, einem funktionierenden Modell in der Lage ist, das Problem zu lösen, aber nicht mit einem Regelwerk.
Aber ich schätze mal.
Damit äußerst du doch die größte Kritik überhaupt an der harten KI. Weil die harte KI versucht doch genau, das auf einem deterministischen Automaten so ein Regelwerk zu implementieren. Also was anderes bleibt doch gar nicht übrig, oder? Computers sind doch nicht.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich meine, harte KI, meiner Meinung nach, ist nicht umsonst mittlerweile ein Zweig, der in der Informatik nicht mehr allzu viel Finanzierung erfährt. Weil die haben halt einfach mal 30 Jahre lang nichts zeigen gehabt.
Es gibt diese schöne, irgendwie Marvin Minsky sagt, seit 1965, dass Computer in fünf Jahren denken können.
Genau, aber macht er auch nur, damit er irgendwie... Mehr Geld kriegt, ja. Insofern, also mein Ansatz, es wird in jedem Fall Maschinen geben, die sich mit dir über irgendwie Star Trek unterhalten können. Und das wird halt möglicherweise eine spezialisierte Star Trek Maschine sein. Und wenn du dich mit deinem Roboter über Star Trek unterhalten willst, dann wird er einfach über das Internet diese Star Trek Maschine konnektieren.
Ja, aber das Ding ist...
Er wird keine von Neumann Architektur haben, der intelligente Computer.
Vermutlich nicht.
Aber anders ist es doch in der realen Welt auch nicht. Wenn ich mir irgendwie, wenn ihr einen Griechen vor mich hinstellt, dann geht bei mir auch nichts. Dann kann ich mich zwar mit dem irgendwie mit Händen und Füßen unterhalten, kann irgendwie Gemeinsamkeiten suchen, kann sagen Hunger, Essen, Lala, irgendwie sowas. Mich auf so ganz ganze Basics einlassen. Aber vielleicht entwickelt irgendwann mal eine KI, die uns nicht versteht und die wir nicht verstehen, die aber durchaus ihre eigenen Plane schmiedet und ihre eigenen Bedürfnisse hat.
Gut, aber das moralische Problem, das da aufgetaucht ist, würdest du dann diese Maschine ebenso wie den Griechen zu den Wesen zählen, denen du moralisch zu verhalten zuschreiben kannst und denen über dich dann auch verpflichtet fühlst, dich moralisch zu verhalten?
Das kommt drauf an, ob die Maschine die gleichen Wertevorstellungen entwickelt, wie wir sie entwickelt haben. Vielleicht entwickelt ihr eine Maschine ganz andere Wertevorstellungen als wir ihr haben, auf die wir nur nicht gekommen sind.
Aber wie kannst du Werte haben ohne eine Sprache?
Auf jeden Fall könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass die griechischen Fußballroboter uns die Weltmeisterschaft wegschnappen.
Außerdem fände ich den Griechen nicht so bedrohlich wie den Österreicher oder den Schweizer, den man zwar verstehen kann, der aber trotzdem ein anderes Werte-
und Denksystem hat.
Dominik, vielen Dank für den Ado. Du heilst mir die Kerle zu sehr auf. Mit euch kann man echt nicht nach draußen gehen.
Ein schöner Diskurs.
Wir geben ab zu den Nachrichten.
Freue ich mich, dass es so was wie Uhrzeiten gibt.
In Fritz in Neukölln, dann 102, 6.
Es kann glatt werden bei minus 1 bis minus 4 Grad. Morgen soll es meist bewölkt sein. Ab und zu kann es weiter Schnee geben. Bei maximal 1 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Gerald Kütterheim.
Die gesetzlichen Krankenkassen haben das vergangene Jahr mit einem Millionenüberschuss abgeschlossen. Mehrere große Kassen gaben ihre Zahlen für das Jahr 2004 bekannt. Die deutsche Angestelltenkasse zum Beispiel hat ein Plus von 365 Millionen Euro verzeichnet. Sie erwägt nun für ihre versicherten Mitte des Jahres die Beiträge über das gesetzlich geforderte 0, 9 Prozentpunkte hinaus zu senken. In der Affäre um massenhaften Visa Missbrauch steht Bundesaußenminister Fischer weiter unter Druck. Es geht vor allem um die Frage, wann Fischer welche Details erfahren hat. Nach Medienberichten wusste das Auswärtige Amt bereits im Sommer 2002 von den Missständen an der Botschaft in Kiew. Unklar bleibt heute, inwieweit diese Warnungen Fischer erreichten. Verbraucherschützer haben die geplanten neuen Tarife der Telekom als zu unübersichtlich kritisiert. Kunden müssten ihren Bedarf ganz genau prüfen. Die Telekom hatte angekündigt, dass Telefonieren im Festnetz ab März billiger wird. Das Unternehmen verspricht den Kunden bis zu 75 Prozent Einsparungen im City-Bereich und 59 Prozent weniger Kosten bei Ferngesprächen. In der dritten Runde des UEFA Pokals hat Schalke 04 bei Schachtier Donetsk ein 1 zu 1 Unentschieden erreicht. Der FC Parma spielte gegen den VfB Stuttgart 0 zu 0 Unentschieden. Und im Kampf um den deutschen Basketball Pokal steht Alba Berlin im Viertelfinale. Die Berliner gewannen im Achtelfinale 104 zu 60 beim Zweitligisten Röndorf. Der Verkehr auf Fritz keine Aktuellenmeldung.
Gute Fahrt für euch.
Am 26. Februar spielen die Queens of the Stone Age live im Fritz-Club im Postbahnhof. Dieses Konzert war innerhalb von zwei Tagen total ausverkauft. Da dachte sich die Fritz-Musik-Redaktion.
Das gibt's doch überhaupt nicht.
Und dann dachte sich die Fritz-Musik-Redaktion.
Da müssen wir was machen.
Ja, da müssen wir was machen.
Ja, los, dann machen wir was.
Und deshalb spielen die Queens of the Stone Age für alle, die keine Karten mehr gekriegt haben, einen Tag vor ihrem Fritz-Tub-Konzert live bei Fritz im Radio. Queens of the Stone Age, das exklusive Fritz-Radio-Konzert. Freitag, 25. Februar.
Live in den Fritz-Studios.
Chaos Radio, Aufritz im Blue Moon. Wir haben noch 25 Minuten Zeit und bevor wir es vergessen, das hat Tim auch gerade ganz richtig gesagt, nennen ihn hier noch mal an erster Stelle. Er hat sich vorhin etwas von der Schifffahrt und verkauft gefühlt.
MaxBot.
Neben dem Sitz der Pavel.
MaxBot, aus.
Meine Fernbedienung geht nicht.
Tim trägt Termine vor.
Ja, naja, wir sind ja hier auch sozusagen auch nur Menschen der Chaos Computer Club.
Im Namen des Chaos unterwegs.
Genau, im Namen des Chaos unterwegs, insbesondere des Chaos Computer Club Berlin. Und wer Lust hat, sich mal uns anzuschauen oder mal zuzustoßen. Was es losmacht.
Nicht füttern.
Bitte nicht füttern.
Donnerstags haben wir unseren Club Discordia, unseren offenen Tag. Das findet ihr alles unter berlin.ccc.de. Von Zeit zu Zeit gibt es auch einen Datengarten. Ich glaube, der nächste ist für März geplant, wo Vorträge, Workshops und ähnliche Sachen veranstaltet werden. Ja, im nächsten Monat, ich glaube, der Termin rutscht gerade jetzt auf Anfang Mai. Das ist halt derzeit alles noch ein bisschen durcheinander mit dem Termin mit Chaos Radio. Allerdings sieht es so aus, als ob wir uns jetzt in ein Vier-Wochen-Rhythmus annähern werden. Das heißt, es wird in Zukunft tendenziell eher mehr Chaos Radio geben, dann auch mehr Chaos. Und die nächste Sendung, da wir ja nun die 33 eingeschoben haben, ganz frech, wird halt die hundertste Sendung sein. Und leider kann ich noch nicht so richtig viel dazu sagen, was passieren wird. Aber wir bemühen uns gerade um eine ganz besondere Sendung. Mal gucken, was bei rauskommt. Und im Sommer gibt es dann wieder Open Air Hackereien. Sehr zu empfehlen ist die Veranstaltung What the Hack. Erste Information unter whatthehack.org, also Hack mit A natürlich. Das ist quasi so das Analogon zu unserem Camp, was alle vier Jahre stattfindet. Die holländische Veranstaltung, die auch alle vier Jahre stattfindet, das ist am letzten Juli Wochenende vier Tage. Datum hab ich jetzt nicht genau im Kopf, aber das kriegt ihr ja alle raus. Ihr seid ja filmdich und da ist halt vier Tage, Zelten, Vorträge, tra la la, viele coole Leute, viele coole Projekte. Wir werden als CCC auch dort vor Ort sein und aber natürlich auch viele, viele andere Gruppen, auch sehr viele internationale Gäste sind da zu erwarten. Letztes Mal hatten sie gut 3000 Besucher. Ich denke mal so in der Größenordnung wird sich das wieder abspielen, ist auf jeden Fall die Empfehlung für diesen Sommer. Ja, so viel aus dem Terminkalender.
Die ganzen Infos gibt es auch noch mal unter www.ccc.de zugegebenen Zeitpunkten, nehme ich mal an, oder?
Das auf jeden Fall gab es auch schon. Gibt es aber auch wieder und Berlin CCC.de hier so für den regionalen Kontakt aussetzt.
Was ich schätze, ist diese Präzision und diese Verlässlichkeit, das ist... Gut, 20 Minuten haben wir noch Zeit. Wir sind eigentlich beim Thema Roboter, wollen wir schnell den Jörg ans Telefon nehmen.
Ich wollte was zu künstlicher Intelligenz sagen, dass da ja auch immer ein ökonomisches Interesse im Vordergrund stehen muss, bevor so was überhaupt entwickelt wird. Und das eigentlich eher anzunehmen ist, dass Roboter oder Maschinen entwickelt werden, die nur Teilaufgaben übernehmen, also den Menschen irgendwelche Dienstleistungen abnehmen und diese Dienstleistungen vielleicht komplizierter werden, als sie jetzt von Maschinen abgenommen werden. Aber dass es wahrscheinlich keine Maschinen geben wird, die ganze Menschen simulieren können oder halt mehr Intelligenz in Anführungsstriche haben als Menschen selbst, weil da kein ökonomisches Interesse dahinter steht, so was zu besitzen oder so was zu entwickeln.
Also wie gesagt, good enough Software und wahrscheinlich wird es einfach good enough Robots geben.
Ich glaube, das größte Marktinteresse, so traurig das ist, ist derzeit tatsächlich der militärische Bereich. Also es gibt ja auch einige Firmen, die diese, waren das auch Staubsauger, das Abfallprodukte und die Zivilprodukte?
Muss man halt schon sagen, der Marktführer im Bereich militärische Roboter ist eine Firma, die lustigerweise iRobot heißt. Die ist wiederum auch der Hersteller von diesem lustigen kleinen Staubsauger. Also was wir da halt sehen, ist halt eine klassische Recycling von militärischer Technologie halt im Haushaltsbereich.
Genau, also das, was die Feinde sozusagen in der Ferne abschießt jeden Tag und durch die Gegend fährt und kostensparend, also menschenkostensparend sozusagen den Krieg ferngesteuert durchführt, das reinigt einem auch das Klo. Das ist doch eigentlich eine schöne Vision. Aber mit Intelligenz hat das alles nicht zu tun.
Aber auch da ist ja nur anzunehmen, dass diese Maschinen für bestimmte Aufgaben konzipiert sind und nicht eigenmächtig dann irgendwas entscheiden, was jetzt als nächstes zu tun ist.
Die sind dafür da, eigenmächtig zu entscheiden, wer als nächstes abzuschießen ist.
Ja, aber halt nur für die Aufgabe des Abschießens da sind.
Wer macht den Soldat aber auch nicht.
Ja, er ist ja auch nur zum Einsetzen oder für eine Aufgabe da.
Aber es sind schon, ich gebe dir da recht, also ich tue mich auch immer schwer, die Dinger wirklich als als Roboter zu bezeichnen, weil es sind doch eher ferngesteuerte Automaten und die Intelligenz im Wesentlichen. Also sie haben vielleicht im besten Fall Reflexe, mit denen sie Terrain, Unebenheiten ausgleichen und dann vielleicht noch ein Ziel-Suchsystem, wobei vermutlich das Markieren des Ziels wiederum durch irgendwelche vorgeschobenen Spezialeinheiten erfolgt oder wiederum durch einen Operator, der dann von der Kamera sitzt und dann doch derjenige ist, der letztendlich auf den Knopf drückt.
Also so die Entscheidung immer noch von Menschen getroffen wird.
Nee, das ist tatsächlich nicht so. Also wenn du dir zum Beispiel mal so den einfachsten Zielvernichtungsroboter anguckst, dann ist das eine große Missile von 1982, die über Terrain-Matching und Matching eines Objektes, das zu vernichten ist, mit einem vorgegebenen Bild tatsächlich irgendwie die Vernichtung durchführt. Das heißt also die, die dann schon recht autonom agiert hat und mittlerweile sind diese Dinger schon recht weit. Es gibt also zum Beispiel Anti-Panzersysteme, die schießt du halt einfach in einen vorgegebenen Luftraum und die kreisen da und warten darauf, dass der Gegner sein Panzer aus der Garage fährt. Und zwar egal wo in diesem Gebiet. Die haben halt ein vorgegebenes Gebiet und wenn in diesem Gebiet ein Panzer aus der Garage fährt, dann fliegen sie halt hin und sprengen den. Also das ist halt so Stand der Technik von heute. Also nicht irgendwas wesentlich in der Zukunft liegen. Und ich denke genau diese Teilautomatisierung von solchen Tasks ist eigentlich genau das, wo die Zukunft liegt. Und so spezialisierte Systeme lassen sich auch relativ gut entwickeln. Wie gesagt, deswegen meine ich ja, dass es in Zweifel irgendwo eine KI geben wird, die sich mit Star Trek auskennt. Und wenn du über Star Trek reden willst, dann wird ein Haushaltsroboter sich einfach mit der connecten.
Bei einem Roboter, der auf Menschen losgelassen wird, das kann ich mir höchstens dann vorstellen, wenn die Menschen mit irgendeinem RFID-Pass in der Gegend rumlaufen, als eindeutige Identifikation.
Also da halte ich biometrische Verfahren durchaus für eine Option. Also so eine Gesichtserkennung von so einem durch die Gegend watschelnden Roboter. Also angenommen, wir hätten jetzt mal so diesen Replikanten-Style, der also schon so halbwegs attraktiv durch die Gegend marschieren kann. Da sollte es ja nicht so das große Problem sein, ein anderes Gesicht zu erkennen.
Also im Kommunikationsmuseum gibt es auf dem großen Saal gibt es zwei Roboter, sind relativ simple Systeme. Der eine fährt einem blauen Ball hinterher und der andere guckt nach Besuchern, fährt auf die Besucher zu und begrüßt sie. Also der ist schon schlicht in der Lage, einen Menschen von irgendwie seinem Roboterkollegen und von einem blauen Ball problemlos zu unterscheiden.
Aber er begrüßt dich nicht mit meinem Namen.
Nö, er begrüßt dich noch nicht mit deinem Namen, aber spätestens wenn der einfach dir in den Pass ist, wird er auch das können.
Aber wenn ich mir da zwei weiße oder schwarze Streifen ins Gesicht malen würde, dann wäre der eigentlich schon aufgeschmissen.
Das machst du aber in der Regel nicht und deswegen reicht wieder Good Enough Robotics aus.
Aber es geht hier dabei immer nur um die Simulation von Intelligenz durch Algorithmen. Also dass es halt immer kompliziertere Algorithmen gibt, die dann Intelligenz simulieren können, dass man aber eigentlich noch nicht rausbekommen hat, was Intelligenz selbst eigentlich ist, um das dann nachbauen zu können. Also ich habe...
Also wie gesagt, meine Thesis, da gibt es schlicht keinen Markt für.
Der halt mit mathematischen Beweisen nachweist, dass es eigentlich mit Algorithmen nicht zielführend ist, in künstliche Intelligenz zu entwickeln, sondern dass es halt mit diesen Algorithmen irgendwann zu einem Ende kommt, dass bestimmte Aufgaben nicht mehr gelöst werden können, sondern der Algorithmus sich dann totläuft, also keine Lösung mehr dabei rauskommt. Deswegen halt, die Intelligenz nicht simuliert werden kann.
Es gibt natürlich noch die anderen Ansätze zu sagen, man versucht es auf irrationellem Wege, das heißt also, man lässt Maschinen aus ihren eigenen Fehlern lernen, um sozusagen nicht explizit diesen Algorithmus entwickeln zu müssen, sondern die Maschine selbst den Algorithmus entwickeln zu lassen. Also genetische Algorithmen und neuronale Netze sind da so ein Thema. Und da ist es natürlich auch so, dass nicht auszuschließen ist, dass der Siliziumweg halt der falsche ist. Also es kann natürlich sein, dass es mit einem normalen Computer einfach normal architekturisch nicht geht, sondern man halt einfach neuronale Netze, die es halt schon in Bio-Form gibt, halt einfach benutzt, um solche Dinge zu tun. Also das letzte Ergebnis, was da gab, war Ratten, Hirnzellen fliegen an einem simulierten Kampfjet. Und vielleicht ist das ja auch der Weg, der da irgendwie zum Ziel führt und nicht halt irgendwie beste Computer-Algorithmen.
Wobei die neuronalen Netze könnten werfen dann auch noch interessante rechtliche Probleme auf. Es gab nämlich, also die sind beispielsweise für bestimmte Anwendungsbereiche verboten, wo es nämlich darum geht, eine gewisse Sicherheit herzustellen. Bei einem neuronalen Netz kann man aber nicht wirklich schlüssig nachweisen, dass dieses unter bestimmten Bedingungen oder Parametern tatsächlich richtig funktioniert. Weil es kann halt immer sein, dass es eben mal was anderes tut.
Und man kann es halt nicht vollständig testen. Nicht vollständig mathematisch beweisen.
Okay, Jörg, danke dir erstmal für den Anruf. Wir haben noch zwei Anrufer und haben knapp Zeit nur noch. So, der Robert aus Zählen auf Hei Robert. Guten Abend.
Ich wollte eigentlich nur mal zurückgreifen auf Vorredner. Also ich hab seinen Namen vergessen. Egal, wenn ihr auch auf eine relativ chaotische Diskussion mit diesem chinesischen Zimmer und Gedankenexperimenten und was weiß ich und ähnlichen Schlussformen. Ich glaube, vor allem wenn man sich auf einem Gebiet künstlichen Intelligenz entwickelt oder so, dann würde ich mit solchen Betrachtungen sehr vorsichtig sein und das Eventual auch mal so ein bisschen außen vorschieben, weil jeder noch am Ende so ein bisschen gesagt hat, vielleicht hab ich schon eine künstliche Intelligenz programmiert, die eigentlich im Prinzip intelligent ist, die ich nur selber nicht verstehe, weil sie auf eine andere Art und Weise denkt oder ähnliches. Sondern ich denke, wenn man sich vor allem, wenn man so etwas abwässt, so präzise Parameter vorgeben, einfach halt eben so, das muss das Ding können und wenn ich ihm einen gewissen Input gebe oder so, dann muss er mir das anfangen können. Aber darum denke ich auch, dass so eine Intelligenz sich nicht jetzt entwickeln lässt wie ein Mensch, sondern eher wirklich, was er auch vorher als Beispiel hatte, als militärische Organisation oder so, wo wirklich nur eine gewisse limitierte Menge an Zielen hatte, an Funktionen, die das Ding wirklich ausführen können muss und der Rest ist einfach mal egal. Also man reitet sich, glaube ich, wenn man so anfängt extrem präzise darüber nachzudenken, was macht, was ist eigentlich Intelligenz, was macht so eine Intelligenz eigentlich, was muss so ein Programm machen, reitet man sich, glaube ich, sehr schnell in ein ziemlich kompliziertes Paradox von rein, wo man dann irgendwie selber nicht mehr so wirklich weiß, ob man intelligent ist oder nicht.
Es gibt auch verschiedene Schulen da in der Psychologie, die sich überhaupt nicht einig darüber sind, was denn natürlich Intelligenz oder Intelligenz überhaupt ist. Und insofern werden wir das wahrscheinlich auch nicht wirklich geklärt, kriegen heute Abend.
Knapp nicht mehr. Wir hätten es geschafft, wenn wir fünf...
Also künstliche Intelligenz ist für mich so etwa der Level aus dem Fernsehen.
Leutnant, Leutnant Commander Data, ich bin vollständig in behörschung motif der Technik.
Ja, den Humor nicht verlieren. Ja, Robert.
Das ist halt immer so, was ich weiß, ich weiß immer um eine Frage, die man, die finde ich auch immer sehr interessant, wie gesagt, in so einem Zusammenhang, die eigentlich auch nicht so wirklich was führt. Hat man eigentlich eventuell schon eine Intelligenz programmiert, die man selber noch nicht versteht oder? Kann ja auch sein, dass man sich auf vieles mal die Intelligenz programmiert, die auf eine in sich geschlossene warteweise logisch denkt, die der Programmierer aber selbst einfach nicht versteht.
Ich glaube manchmal, ich hätte bei Tim einen Fehler gemacht, aber ein Markswort.
Also ich glaube, da verläuft man sich dann dran.
Ich glaube, dass die meisten Programmierer ihre Programme nicht wirklich verstehen.
Also von daher, Intelligenz.
Aber Intelligenz sind die nicht wirklich.
Ja, Intelligenz ist so ein schwieriges Wort. Ich glaube, dass keiner so genau weiß, was er eigentlich meint.
Ja, die Betriebswerte bzw. Wirtschaftswissenschaftler haben die die einzige wirklich brauchbare oder nicht brauchbare, sondern zumindest logische Definition von Intelligenz, die einem aber auch nicht wirklich weiterhilft. Da ist es nämlich so, Intelligenz ist das, was von Intelligenztests gemessen wird.
Das brauchen wir nur noch, wenn wir die Intelligenz-Tests ein bisschen übliche Ergebnisse ausspucken, dann können wir sagen, ja klar, kann man sehen.
Die Vivis.
Danke für den Anruf, Robert. So, letzter ist Josef aus Dresden.
Hi Josef.
Du bist der Letzte in der Runde. Du hast das Schlusswort. Überlege dir wohl, was du sagst.
Nee, ich wollte sagen, also wenn wir irgendwann 20 Jahre oder so oder 10 Roboter eigentlich alles, was wir so besitzen, also was sie in der Hand haben, dann könnte es so leicht passieren, dass ein Virus entsteht und dass wir dann alles wieder verlieren, oder? Dass wir dann wieder auf dem Nullpunkt sind.
Ja, das war glaube ich im Chat vorhin auch ein Thema, dass ein Virus die ganze Roboterpopulation dahin rafft und vielleicht so eine Art Selbstmordvirus unter Robotern vielleicht grassiert und sie sich alle dann die Köpfe abreißen oder einfach das Flash löschen.
Oder in die Ecke setzen und schmollen.
Oder einfach die falschen Antworten und irgendwas manipulieren oder so also so zum Beispiel eine Fabrik oder so was.
Die sind ja in der Literatur schon geschrieben worden.
Hinreichend, ja.
Marwinde.
Ja, war nicht depressiv. Ja, Josef, schade wir dachten wir erzählen uns noch was Schönes mit Robotern, aber dann müssen wir halt mit einer schlimmen Zukunftsvision schließen. Vielen Dank für den Anruf. Gruß nach Dresden.
Max will nur beweisen, dass er kein Roboter ist.
Früher gab es hier Rolls-Ball-Tasten an den Mikrofonen.
Klar, aber nicht. Da müsste ich bei euch auch drücken mit allen Füßen und Händen, die ich habe. Das würde nicht funktionieren.
Nein, Marius, wozu hast du die sechs Arme bitte?
Gut, das war's für den heutigen Abend mit dem Chaosradio.
Möchten Sie vielleicht noch ein kleines Schlusswort? Ich hab noch einen Aspekt, den ich noch einbringen will. Und zwar die Roboter, die wir jetzt erst mal so sehen in den nächsten Jahren, werden keine richtigen Roboter im Hollywood-Sinn sein, sondern Telepräsenzmaschinen, also Maschinen, mit denen der Mensch über größere Entfernung hinweg Dinge tun kann. Also ferngesteuerte Autos sind halt nur der Anfang. Roboter, die halt irgendwie in Atomkraftwerken Dinge tun und so weiter und so fort. Also Telepräsenz wird, denke ich mal, ein großes Thema sein. Das, was wir jetzt auch als Drohnen zum Beispiel im Irak sehen, sind eigentlich ja Telepräsenzmaschinen keine Roboter. Das heißt also, die werden, haben limitierte automatische Funktionalität. Die können fliegen, die können ein Ziel angreifen, aber die ultimative Kontrolle hat der Mensch. Und ich denke, das wird noch lange Zeit tatsächlich sein, was passiert und zum Beispiel auch in der Altenpflege diese Roboter. Ich vermute mal, die werden auch erstmal aus einer Art Core Center gesteuert werden. Da wird es irgendwie Leute geben, die 4, 4, 5 Altenpflege Roboter zuständig sind, von mir aus, von zu Hause aus, und halt irgendwie die Kommunikation übernehmen. Und Roboter, die tatsächlich autonome handeln und so weiter und so fort, da ist 2015 vermutlich ein bisschen früh gegriffen. Aber Systeme, die halt Telepräsenz ausführen können, die werden wir doch in aller nächster Zeit sehen können.
Und als Assistenzsysteme werden sie sich auch langsam einschleichen, dass einem immer mehr vom Fahren abgenommen wird.
Vom Fliegen, genau.
Und das Auto oder Verkehrsmittel stellen natürlich auch eine interessante Basis oder evolutionäre Ausgangsbasis für Roboter da, weil sie schon eine Energieversorgung haben, sich bewegen können.
Aber ohne eine Industrie geht es gar nicht. Die Industrie, die immer die neuen Technologien als erste nutzt und nach vorne bringt und damit immer am meisten Geld macht. Na, die Sexindustrie, also VHS, DVD, CD. Das Internet. Das Internet, egal was es ist. Die Internet ist for porn. Es ist einfach Sex driven Business. Und wenn ich mir halt so die Evolution eines Vibrators vorstelle, so hin in die robotische, in die, genau, in die Dildonics oder auch in die Tiledildonics Welt, da geht da einiges. Und ich glaube, das interessiert dann mal wieder richtig viele Leute, damit er dann schlecht einsteigen soll.
Vielleicht machen wir nochmal ein Video.
Ja, Max, aber wie fühlst du dich denn so bei dem Gedanken?
Ich muss einfach dann nur abschließend meine Beurteilung da in dem Bereich treffen und sagen, die Puppen sind leider noch nicht so weit. Das war's mit dem Chaosradio. Wir verabschieden uns ganz herzlich. Macht euch eure eigenen warmen Gedanken. Wir hören uns wieder in vier Wochen vielleicht mit einer besonderen 100. Ausgabe, wie wir alle hoffen. Und jetzt gibt es hier den Neidverd mit Martin Petersdorf. Es verabschieden sich der Tim, der Pavel, der Frank und meine Person der Max. Das schließt sich an.